İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 25 Aralık 2024 çarşamba günü 51. ders günü saat 19.30 dersimize başlıyoruz.
Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Geçen dersimizde Operatör New, Operatör Delete fonksiyonlarını, New ifadelerini ve Delete ifadelerini gördük.
Bunların overload edilmesine değindik.
Ama orada eksik kalan bir nokta daha vardı ki bir de oraya geri dönelim.
Ondan sonra da yavaş yavaş bizim akıllı pointerlarımıza, smart pointerlarımıza gelelim.
Arkadaşlar Operatör New ve Operatör Delete fonksiyonları bir sınıf için,
yani o sınıf türünden dinamik ömürlü nesnelerin oluşturulmasında çağrılabilecek fonksiyonlar olarak overload edilebilir.
Geçen derste şunu söyledim ama bir kez daha vurgulamak istiyorum.
Kursun başında da söylemiştim.
Arkadaşlar New ifadesi yerine programcıların genel kullandığı terim New Operatörü.
Ama şu iki terim birbiriyle karıştırılabiliyor.
New Operatörü başka bir şey arkadaşlar.
New Operator.
Aslında standartın kullandığı terim New Expression.
Ama Operatör New bir fonksiyon.
Operatör New bir fonksiyon.
Yine aynı şekilde Delete Operatörü ya da Delete Expression başka.
Operatör Delete başka.
İkisini birbiriyle karıştırmayalım.
Soru.
New Operatörü overload edilebilir mi?
Bu soruya son bir cevap vermeye çalışın.
Değilim ki bir mülakatta sorular.
New Operatörü overload edilebilir mi?
Cevap.
Hayır.
Bravo Yiğit.
Bravo Oğuzhan Bey.
Hayır.
Çünkü overload edilen New Operatörü değil.
Operatör New fonksiyonu.
Nasıl geçen dersimizde biz Operatör New ve Operatör Delete fonksiyonlarını yazdığımızda
dinamik bellek alanı elde edilmek istendiğinde o fonksiyonlar çağrıldıysa arkadaşlar bir sınıf içinde yine bu fonksiyonları sınıfın statikoya fonksiyonları olarak overload edebiliriz.
Bu durumda bir sınıf kendi dinamik nesnelerinin bellek alanının allocate edilmesini kendisi için özelleştirebilir.
İngilizcesiyle pastimize edebilir.
Örneğin class, my class diyelim ki my class sınıfı nesneleri için örneğin auto p eşittir new my class.
Burada standart kütüphanenin Operatör New fonksiyonu değil ama bu sınıf için özelleştirilmiş bir Operatör New fonksiyonunun çağrılmasını istiyorsanız
hatta bakınız class net net sınıfı için normal standart kütüphanenin Operatör New fonksiyonu çağrılsın.
Fakat my class sınıfı için bu sınıfın belki varlık nedenine daha uygun ya da kullanım biçimine daha uygun
bir Operatör New fonksiyonu gereksin.
Arkadaşlar kural şöyle.
Bu fonksiyonlar sınıfın statik üye fonksiyonları bir kere.
Yani non-statik üye fonksiyonu Operatör New fonksiyonu olarak bildiremezsiniz.
Örneğin Void Yıldız Operatör New
Arkadaşlar size underscore p n
Arkadaşlar bir şey dikkatinizi çekti mi?
Statik anahtar sözcüğünü yazmasam da bu statik üye fonksiyonu.
Normalde daha önce böyle bir durumla karşılaşmadık.
C++ İngilizce gibi hep istisnalara da sahip.
Yani normalde bir fonksiyonu sınıfın içimde bildirsem ya da tanımlarsam
statik anahtar sözcüğünü kullanmadığım sürece non-statik üye fonksiyonu.
Ama burada durum öyle değil.
Mesela bakınız diyelim ki
burada bu fonksiyon şöyle implement edilmiş olsun.
Tabii ki implementasyon normalde böyle olmayacak.
Arkadaşlar
Include
cstd
lib
efendim
malloc
n
void yıldız
vp
eğer vp
null pointer ise
throw
std
bad
log
arkadaşlar
return vp
Ama bu fonksiyonun çağrıldığını belgeleyelim bir şekilde
see out
michaels'in
operatör
new fonksiyonu
std
hatta daha önce yaptığımız gibi
biraz
sidok kazandıralım benim tabirimle
yani biraz storage ihtiyacı olsun sınıfın
ve
buraya gelen
argümanın da ne olduğunu yazalım
yazdıralım
std
n
n eşittir
arkadaşlar
yine benzer şekilde
operator
delete
fonksiyonu
geri dönüş değeri yok ama
sınıfın statik üye fonksiyonu
parametre değişkeni
void yıldız
vp
see out
my class'ın
operatör
delete
fonksiyonu
void yıldız
vp
ve
vp eşit
arkadaşlar
vp
hatta
burada
mallook'un
geri dönüş değerini de yazdıralım
std
see out
vp
new line
alian
hocam
operator new fonksiyonlarındaki
x size t parametresine
gerekli boyut
her zaman implicit olarak mı
geçiyor
bravo
aynen öyle
saplamanız %100
doğru
arkadaşlar
bakınız şimdi
eğer eksik bir şey
kalmadıysa
buraya kadar
derleyelim
sentaks hatalarımızı
düzeltelim
şurada bir noktalı
virgül eksik
tekrar
derleyelim
bir hata yok
ve önce
dinamik ömürlü
neç nesnesi için
arkadaşlar
bakınız
runtime'a
operator new
operator delete
global
olarak
global fonksiyonlar
çağrıldı
oysa
my class sınıfı için
arkadaşlar görüyorsunuz
operator new fonksiyonu
v
hatta
delete p
dediğimde
operator
delete fonksiyonu
çağrıldı
şimdi şu
uzun uzun konuşmamız
gereken bir konu ki
biraz
zamandan da
tasarruf etmek için
ileri C++
kursunda ayrıntılı
anlatıyorum
neden
örneğin
operator new
ve operator delete'i
bir şekilde
overload
etmek isteyelim
yani kimse
yani kimse durup dururken
operator new
ve operator delete'i
ne yapmaz
overload etmez
ne global olarak
ne de
arkadaşlar
bir sınıf için
yani bir kere
böyle bir
operator fonksiyonu
bir operator new
fonksiyonu
overload etmeniz
söz konusuysa
elinizde makul
neden ya da
nedenler olması
gerekiyor
mesela
arkadaşlar
standart kütüphanenin
kullandığı
operator new
size sunduğu
genel bir
allocator
oysa
örneğin
sizin sınıfınızın
kullanılma
biçimine
bağlı olarak
farklı şekilde
tahsisat
yapan
eskilerin
deyimiyle
fonksiyon
gerekebilir
mesela
çok küçük
nesneler için
daha etkili
daha hızlı
allocation
yapmak
farklı
algoritmalarla
mümkün
ya da
örneğin
gömüle sistem
programlama
tarafında
belki
arkadaşlar
dinamik
bellek yönetimini
söz konusu
olmadığı
yani bir
heap alanının
söz konusu
olmadığı
bir alan
bir domen
bir ortamda
örneğin
statik bir
bellek alanını
ki böyle örnekler
yazıyoruz
aslında
diğer kursta
baştan
allocate edip
orayı
sizin yazdığınız
operator new'in
kontrollü bir
şekilde
arkadaşlar
yönetmesini
sağlayabilirsiniz
hatta
orası
kısıtlı bir
bellek alanı
olabilir
adeta
İngilizcese
bir
recycling
algoritması
oluşturabilirsiniz
yani
bir
nesnenin
hayatı
bittiğinde
onun yeri
bu seferde
başka bir
nesne için
kullanılacak
ama
statik bir
bellek alanı
söz konusu
böylece
hem
allocation
maliyeti
düşecek
hem de
sizin sınıfınız
için
daha
özelleştirilmiş
olacak
ya da örneğin
dinamik
bellek
yönetiminde
arkadaşlar
bir
kaçak var mı
memorilik
var mı
onu kontrol etmek
için belki
özel bir
geçici süre
için kullanmak
amaçlı
bir
operatörün
fonksiyonunu
yazabilirsiniz
birçok neden
olabilir
ama doğrusu
isterseniz
bunlar daha
çok
kütüphaneleri
geliştiren
programcıların
yaptığı iş
yani normal
üretimde
kullanan
çalışan
başkalarının
yazdığı
kütüphaneleri
ya da standart
kütüphaneyi
kullanarak
işini gören
programcıların
buna çok sık
ihtiyaç duyacağını
söyleyemem
arkadaşlar
şimdi
neci
michaelastan
kalıtım yoluyla
elde edersek
michaelastaki
new fonksiyonu
ne için
kullanabilir miyiz
işte bu da
çok güzel bir soru
cevap doğrudan
hayır
onun için
operatör
new'i de
ona uygun bir
şekilde yazmamız
gerekiyor
o yüzden
burada
aslında saatlerce
konuşmak mümkün
ama
isterseniz
onları
biraz daha
ileri bir
kapsamda
ayrıca
ele almakta
fayda var
ona bırakalım
çünkü
sorularında
sonu gelmez
çok fazla
detay var
burada
geçen
derste de
epey zaman
harcadık
zaten
ama şu
andaki
bilgilerimizin
yeterli
olduğunu
eğer
bu
kütüphane
geliştirmiyorsak
bu bilgilerle
işimizi
görebileceğimizi
söyleyebiliriz ki
şimdi
akıllı
pointer
konusuna
geleceğiz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
pointerlar
c'nin
vazgeçilmezi
fakat
c++'da
evet pointerları
kullanıyoruz
hatta
gördüğünüz
bazı ifadeler
önemli ifadeleri
pointer
üretiyorlar
yani pointerları
dilden
tamamen silmek
mümkün değil
bu yönde
öneriler olsa da
arkadaşlar
evet evet
pointerların
kullanımı giderek
azalıyor
duruma göre
pointer yerine
referans
semantiğini
kullanıyoruz
duruma göre
pointer like
sınıfları
kullanıyoruz
duruma göre
akıllı
pointerları
kullanıyoruz
ama bu
pointerlara
duyulan
ihtiyacın
tamamen
yok olduğu
anlamına
kesinlikle
gelmiyor
ben şimdi
biraz
pointerların
arkadaşlar
problemlerinden
bahsedeceğim
benim böyle
konuştuğuma
bakmayın
pointerların
problemi yok
aslında
ama pointerları
kullanmakta
programcılar
problemle
karşılaşıyorlar
çünkü zor
o yüzden
pointerların
dezavantajları
demek
belki doğru
değil
ama pointerların
işimizi zorlaştırdığı
kodlama hatası
riskini
arttırdığı
durumlardan
bahsedelim
ya da
kodun
okunmasını
yazılmasını
zorlaştıran
yönlerinden
bahsedelim
arkadaşlar
bir koda
bakıyorsunuz
ve
diyelim ki
o kodda
michael as
isimli bir
sınıf var
kodu okuyup
anlamaya
çalışıyorsunuz
ve
kodun
bir yerinde
herhangi bir yerde
bir michael as
pointerı
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
böyle bir
pointer
size
kendisinin
pointer olduğunu
koda bakarak
yani
statik türünden
zaten
söylüyor
michael as
yıldız olduğuna
göre
bu bir
pointer
ama bakın
doğrudan
ilave başka
yerlere
bakmazsak
ya da
kodun
belirli
kısımlarını
inceleyip
onları
anlamazsak
şu soruların
cevabını
doğrudan
vermiyor
arkadaşlar
bir kere
p
bir nesneyi
gösteriyorsa
p'nin
diyelim ki
p
null pointer
değil
geçerli bir
pointer
ve bir nesneyi
gösteriyor
söyleyin bakalım
şimdi
koda bakarken
belirli bir noktada
mesela sadece
bunun türüne
bakarak
p'nin
a
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesneyi
mi gösterdiğini
yoksa
örneğin
otomatik ömürlü
bir nesneyi
mi gösterdiğini
ya da
statik ömürlü
bir nesneyi
mi gösterdiğini
bilemiyorsunuz
yani onu
belki
p'nin
kullanıldığı
yere bakarak
anlayacaksınız
ve bunu
bilmek son derece
önemli
arkadaşlar
o zaman
birinci problem
bir pointer'ın
türüne
bakarak
pointer
değişkenin
ne amaçla
oluşturulduğunu
doğrudan
türünden
anlama
imkanımız yok
özellikle
burada
örneğin
dinamik ömürlü
nesneleri
gösterecek
pointer'ın
başka
şekillerde
kullanımı
ama
otomatik ömürlü
nesneleri
gösteren
pointer'ın
farklı şekilde
kullanımı
söz konusu
olduğundan
burayı
anlamamız
önemli
arkadaşlar
ikinci önemli
nokta
peki
bu pointer
bir nesneyi
gösteriyor
diyelim
belirli bir
noktada
bu pointer'ın
gösterdiği
nesnenin
hayatından
kim sorumlu
o da
ortada yok
yani
p
dilit mi
edilecek
yoksa
p'nin
hayata
bittiğinde
hiçbir şey
yapılmayacak mı
yoksa
p'nin
başka
kopyaları
da çıkartılmış
o kopyaları
üstünden mi
bir
arkadaşlar
yönetim
söz konusu
ve
bu pointer'ın
kopyalanması
konusunda
bir problem
var mı
yok mu
bunlar da
anlaşılmıyor
yani
bir pointer
statik bir pointer
değişken
bildiğimiz
raw pointer'lardan
bahsediyorum
bir raw pointer
değişken
otomatik
ömürlü
statik ömürlü
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
gösterebilir
bu pointer'ın
hayatı
bittiğinde
ya da
görevi
tamamlandığında
onun
gösterdiği
nesneyi
dilit
etmemiz
gerekebilir
ama
şunu da
söylemiyor
bakın
daha da
tehlikeli bir durum
peki
diyelim ki
p dinamik ömürlü
bir nesneyi
gösteriyor
peki bu nesne
arkadaşlar
böyle mi
oluşturuldu
yoksa
böyle mi
oluşturuldu
yoksa
böyle mi
oluşturuldu
öyle değil mi
farklı farklı
ne ifadeleri
var
yoksa
böyle mi
oluşturuldu
arkadaşlar
bunların
hiçbiri
bilinmiyor
hadi bunları
bildik
pointer'ı
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesneyi
gösteriyor
peki
delete
edelim mi
önemli bir
soru
arkadaşlar
eğer bu
pointer'ın
kopyaları
çıkartılmışsa
o kopyalar
başka
kodlar
tarafından
kullanılmaktaysa
örneğin bu
pointer'ın
kopyalarını
bir
konteynera
ya da
birden fazla
konteynera
insert etmiş
olabilirsiniz
değil mi
biz bu
pointer'ın
gösterdiği
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
bravo
kancan
delete
ettiğimizde
diğer pointer'lar
dangling
hale gelecek
c++
programlarında
en sık
karşılaşılan
kodlama
hatası
programlama
dangling
pointer'ların
kullanılması
dolayısıyla
bunu delete
edebilmemiz
için
bunun bir
kopyasının
çıkarılmadığını
yani
bunun gösterdiği
nesnenin
başka
pointer'lar
tarafından
gösterilmediğini
başka pointer'ların
hayatını kontrol ettiği
nesneye
başka pointer'lar
yoluyla ulaşma
imkanı olmadığından
emin olmalıyız
arkadaşlar
ve az önce
söylediğim gibi
hadi diyelim ki
eminiz
nasıl delete
edeceğim
delete p mi
delete köşeli
parantez p mi
yoksa
arkadaşlar
bravo
olsan
kesinlikle
yoksa
ben hiç
delete ifadesini
kullanmayacağım
not role
mi
olduğu gibi
doğrudan
belki
sınıfın
arkadaşlar
destraktör'ına
eksplicit olarak
çağrı yapacağım
bunların
hiçbirini
bilmiyoruz
hadi diyelim
bunu da
bildik
yani
yazmam gereken
kod
delete
p
peki
delete edeceğim
ya başka bir
işlem daha
yapmam
gerekiyorsa
mesela
bunu
arkadaşlar
delete
ederken
etmekle
yetinmeyip
belki bir yere
loglama da
yapmam
gerekiyor
pointer'ın
kendisi bu
bilgiyi
vermiyor ki
burası da
önemli
arkadaşlar
belki
delete
edilen
nesnelerin
adreslerini
bir
konteynerda
tutacağım
memory
linkle
ilgili
daha sonra
araştırmalar
yapabilmek
için
bunlar da
bilinmiyor
o yüzden
pointer'larla
ilgili
hatalar
çok sık
yapılıyor
yani ne
kadar
becerikli
olursanız olun
ne
kadar
disiplinli
olursanız
olun
pointer'ları
kullanmak
hele hele
belirli
kaynakları
yöneten
pointer'ları
kullanmak
arkadaşlar
biraz zor
ve problemlere
açık
tabii
en önemli
tehlikelerden biri de
hiç
delete
etmemek
bu da
çok
sık
rastlanan
bir durum
arkadaşlar
şu sorunun
cevabını
aman yanlış
vermeyin
ben hep
soruyorum
mesela
bülakatta
diyorum ki
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesneyi
delete
etmezsek
ne olur
hemen
herkesin ilk
cevabı
ne biliyor musunuz
memory
ilk olur
bu cevap
doğru mu
cevap
bu soru
doğru mu
sorusunun
arkadaşlar
resource leak
olayı
bravo
arkadaşlar
yani memory leak
de resource leak
karıştırmayalım
memory leak
nasıl olabilir
örneğin
operator new
fonksiyonu
çağrılmıştır
size of my class
256 byte
ve 256 byte
bir
benlek alanı
ilgili
operator new
tarafından
allocate
edilmiştir
arkadaşlar
fakat
delete
etmezsek
destructor
çağrılmaz
destructorın
çağrılmaması
demek
eğer bu
bir
rayı
objekse
destructorın
çağrılmaması
bu nesnenin
hayata gelirken
ya da daha
sonradan
edindiği
kaynakların
geri verilmemesi
demek
bu da ciddi
bir problem
değil mi
arkadaşlar
daha önce de
konuşmuştuk
bakın ben
hep örnek olarak
şu kodu gösteriyorum
çünkü
yeni başlayanların
çok sık karıştırdığı
bir durum
diyorum ki
bakın bakın
koda şimdi
auto
ps
eşittir
new
sputstring
arkadaşlar
100.000 tane
abartalım
a karakteri
e şimdi
bu dinamik
ömürlü bir nesne mi
evet
peki
burada
kaç tane
allocation var
arkadaşlar
iki tane
biri
size of string kadar
hatta ben
hatırlarsanız
kursun başlarında
operator new
ve operator delete
fonksiyonlarını
overload ederek
arkadaşlar
bunu göstermiştim
bir
diyelim ki
32 byte olsun
size of string
kadar bir
bellek alanı
operator new
fonksiyonu
tarafından
allocate
edilecek
ama bir
bir de
string nesnesinin
bu yazıyı
tutmak için
heap'te
ihtiyaç duyduğu
bir bellek alanı var
o bellek alanını da
yine
dinamik olarak
allocate
edecek
şimdi ben
delete
etmezsem
a
arkadaşlar
destructor
çağrılmayacak
oysa
string sınıf nesnesi
için destructor
çağrıldığında
o diyelim ki
100.000 byte'lık
bellek bloğunu
de allocate
edecekti
öyle değil mi
ama
o işlem
yapılmayacak
yani
iki tane
memory leak
var burada
biri
resource olan
memorinin
leak olması
sızdırması
öbürü
storage için
dinamik
ömürlü
string nesnesinin
storage için
allocate
edilen
bellek bloğunun
geri verilmemesi
ama şimdi
bakın
diyelim ki
file diye bir sınıf var
adı üstünde
file sınıfı
türünden bir nesne
bir dosyayı
temsil ediyor
arkadaşlar
siz şöyle bir
kod yazdınız
new
file
ahmet
nokta
pxt
altın çizmesine
bakmayın
arkadaşlar
efendim
auto
pp
size of file
100 ise
100 byte'lık
bir bellek alanı
operatörün
ile allocate
edildi
ama
muhtemelen bu sınıf
şöyle
implement edildi
değil mi
burada resource'un
kendisi bir dosya
bir file
constructor gidecek
ahmet.txt dosyasını
örneğin
oluşturacak
destructor da
bu dosyayı
kapatacak
siz şimdi
bu nesneyi
delete etmediğiniz
zaman
arkadaşlar
file sınıfının
destructor'ı
çağrılmayacak
file sınıfının
destructor'ı
çağrılmadığı
içinde
destructor
çağrılsaydı
söz konusu
dosyayı
kapatacaktı
bravo
diyor ki
Mehmet Can
ve file
end'ları da
kilitli olarak
kalacak
ama bir de
size of file
kadar
bellek alanının
deavocate
edilmemesi
problemi var
ikisini
birbiriyle
karıştırmamak
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
en büyük
problem de
aslında
dinamik
ömürlü
nesneler için
new ifadeleriyle
oluşturulmuş
exception
ending
burası
başa bela
yani
sırf bu
nedenden bile
dinamik ömürlü
nesneleri
pointer'larla
raw pointer'larla
yönetmek
ayaklarını
kontrol etmek
iyi bir fikir
değil
mesela
bakın
void
fang
int
n
ee
burada
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir ifade var
yine altın
çizmesine
bakmayın
ya da
bakın
fark etmez
benim için
önemli olan
konuyu
anlamanız
class
my class
any
class
mesela
burada
arkadaşlar
new
my class
n
dinamik ömürlü
bir
my class
dizisi oluşturulmuş
auto
p
ve
işi bittiğinde
fonksiyondan
çıkmadan önce
delete edilmiş
buraya kadar bir problem yok
ama
delete edilmesinden önce
başka fonksiyonlar
çağrılmış
full
any
function
ya full fonksiyonu
exception
throw
ederse
full fonksiyonu
exception
throw
ederse
bu durumda
programın akışı
fun fonksiyondan
çıkacak
delete
ifadesini
görmeyecek
delete ifadesini
görmediği için de
dinamik ömürlü
nesneler
delete edilmeyecek
yanlış anlaşılmasın
exception
yakalansa
dahi
dolayısıyla
arkadaşlar
resource
değil olacak
bu da ne
demek
bu fonksiyon
basic
exception
garanti
bile
sağlamıyor
demek
en büyük
risklerden biri de
exception
handling
tarafında
kaynak
sızdırması
burada dikkat
bakın tekrar söylüyorum
exception
yakalansa da
bu dinamik ömürlü
nesneler
delete edilmemiş
olacak
o zaman böyle
durumlarda
eğer elimizde
başka araçlar
olmasaydı
burada
exception
gönderme ihtimali
olan kodu
try blue
içinde alıp
burada
delete
edecektik
ama
eğer exception
göndermezse
ikinci bir
delete ifadesi
daha yazacaktık
ya peki
böyle
dinamik ömürlü
nesnelerin sayısı
birden fazlaysa
iç içe
bloklardaysa
o zaman
o kodu
yazana aşk olsun
okuyana aşk olsun
çok daha
zor olacak
arkadaşlar
neresinden
bakarsanız
dinamik ömürlü
nesnelerin
hayatlarının
kontrol edilmesi
ham pointerlarla
bu türkçe terimi
ana dili türkçü
olmayan arkadaşlar
için
belki başka
anlama gelmesin
ham pointer
benim türkçe
kullandığım
terim
ingilizcedeki
raw pointerı
birebir
türkçeye
çeviriyorum
bazıları da
naked pointer
diyor
işte bütün bu
süreçleri
kolaylaştırmak
için
bizim ilave
bazı
araçlara
ihtiyacımız var
ve hemen şunu
söyleyelim ki
ilave araçlar
sadece akıllı
pointerlar değil
arkadaşlar
çünkü neden
bakınız
her zaman
dinamik ömürlü
nesnelerle
kaynaklar
kontrol edilmiyor
bakın şimdi
C++'da da
biz
ya bazı
C++
kütüphanelerinde
ya C++'dan
C API'lerine
kullandığımız yerde
klasik
handle sistemini
de kullanıyoruz
mesela
bakınız
böyle bir
fonksiyon olsun
create
arkadaşlar
list
geri dönüş
değeri
list handle
efendim
bir bal list
oluşturuyor
bir C
apisi
böyle bir
fonksiyon var
aslında
list handle
bir
pointer türü
fakat
işte
bir takım
fonksiyonlar
var
örneğin
push
back
fonksiyonu
list handle
alıyor
efendim
print
list
fonksiyonu
handle
alıyor
gibi
basit
iştirilmiş
olarak
yazıyor
ama
biliyorsunuz
bu
handle
sisteminde
create
ya da open
fiillerini
taşıyan
tipik olarak
ismi
fonksiyonların
bir de
temizlik
yapan
karşılığı
var
örneğin
destroy
list
arkadaşlar
ismi destroy
olabilir
duruma göre
clean
olabilir
clean up
ama
şimdi bu
programcının
sorumluluğunda
eğer
programcı
create
listi çağırıp
listeyi
kullanmışsa
fakat
destroy
listi çağırmamışsa
problem var
işte bu
C'deki
aslında
constructor
destructor
C'deki
bir nevi
karşılığı
handle
sistemi
peki
şimdi ne
yapacağız
düşünsenize
burada doğrudan
birimik ömürlü
nesne
söz konusu
değil ki
en azından
görünür
katman da
söz konusu
değil
yani siz
bu
API'yi
kullanırken
gideceksiniz
arkadaşlar
create
list
fonksiyonunu
çağıracaksınız
create
listin
geri dönüş
değerini
bir
pointer
değişkende
o handle
dediğimiz
pointer
değişkende
tutacaksınız
işiniz
bittiğinde
de
destroy
liste
bunu göndereceksiniz
artık göndermemek
derleyicinin
bir kontrolüne
de tabi
değil
yani buradan
şunu anlatmaya
çalışıyorum
kaynak
dinamik ömürlü
nesnelerle
sınırlı
değil
kaynak
dinamik ömürlü
nesne
olmaya da
bilir
zordan pointerlarla
yönetilen bir
kaynak
olabilir
bu durumlarda
ne yapmamız
gerekiyor
işin içine
bir de
o zaman önce
söylediğim gibi
exception
handling
girdiğinde
durum
çok daha
karmaşık
bir hal
oluyor
işte
buradaki
elimizdeki
araç
setinde
tekrar tekrar
söylüyorum
tek bir araç
yok
birden fazla
araç var
bunlardan biri
akıllı
pointerlar
modern c++'dan
önce
geçen dersimizde
de biraz
bahsetmiştim
taşımlı
semantiyi
bilin
doğal araçlarıyla
doğrudan
implemente
edilemediği
için
herkesin
belirli yerde
belki kullanmak
zorunda kaldığı
ama
herkesin de
şikayetçi
olduğu
bir
otop
itiyar
sınıfı
vardı
modern c++'la
birlikte
otop
itiyar
sınıfı
önce
deprecate
edildi
sonra da
dilden
tamamen
kaldırıldı
modern c++'la
birlikte
arkadaşlar
kaynakları
kontrol etmek
bu kaynaklara
dinamik ömrülüğü
nesneler de
dahil
dinamik ömrülüğü
nesneleri
diliyet
etme
damping
pointer
oluşturma
vesaire
enrislerini
minimize
etmek
aynı
zaman
da
arkadaşlar
bütün
bunları
yaparken
ilave
bir
maliyetle
yüklememek
amaçlı
kullanılan
bir sınıf
hatta
birden fazla
sınıf var
bunları
öğrenmek
zorundayız
ve çok da
sık kullanacağız
okuduğumuz
kodlarda da
çok sık
kullanıldığını
göreceğiz
arkadaşlar
nereden
başlayalım
öncelikle
bu sınıfların
hepsinin
3 tane
sınıftan
bahsedeceğim
bu konu
başlayıp
altında
aşağı yukarı
12 saat
söyleyecek
bu konu
hepsinin
ya da
9 saat
diyelim
hepsinin
başlık
dosyası
memory
yani
birazdan
ismini sayacağım
sınıflar
söz konusu
olduğunda
onları
kullanmak
için
memory
başlık
dosyasını
include
etmeniz
gerekiyor
ve
c++
standartıyla
eklenen
sınıflardan
bahsediyoruz
ancak
şunu da
söylemeliyiz ki
c++
11 ile
bu sınıflar
dile eklendi
fakat
ve bazı
tabi global
fonksiyonlar
fakat
c++
17 ile
yine
bazı
eklemeler
yapıldı
c++'ın
tipik
gelişimi
böyle değil mi
3 tane
sınıf var
fakat bizi
başlangıçta
ilgilendiren
ilk 2 sınıf
çünkü
3.
sınıf
aslında
yardımcı bir
sınıf
1.
sınıfımız
unique
ptr
sınıf diyorum
ben
sınıf
şablonuyla
arasında
doğrudan
terminolojik
olarak
özellikle
vurgulamak
gerekmiyorsa
bir fark
özetmiyorum
ya eğer
bir sınıf
şablondan
bahsediyorsa
jenerik
sınıf
diyorum
jenerik
class
ya da
açık açık
arkadaşlar
class
template
terimini
kullanıyorum
unique
ptr
diğer sınıfı
ise
shared
ptr
ikisi de
akıllı
pointer
sınıfı
şimdi akıllı
pointer
smart pointer
derken
kast edilen ne
bir kere
gerek
unique ptr
shared ptr
bizim daha önce
kullandığımız
terminoloji ile
pointer like
sınıflar
yani ptr
normal
ham ptr
sağladığı
interfejse
benzer
duruma göre
biraz farklılıklar
olabilir
fakat
çoğunlukla da
ilave
interfejleri
var
yani
bir pointer
değişkeni
kullanmaya
alışıksak
arkadaşlar
smart
pointer
sınıfları da
pointer like
o şekilde
kullanabiliyoruz
ama pointer like
sınıflar
eğer
dinamik ömürlü
nesnelerin
ya da
kaynakların
hayatlarını
yani onların
lifespanlerini
kontrol etmek
amaçlı
kullanılıyorlarsa
böyle sınıflara
smart pointer
sınıfı
deniyor
yani
her smart pointer
sınıfı
bir pointer
like
class
ama her
pointer like
class
bir smart pointer
sınıfı
olmak zorunda
değil
yani
hem bir pointer
interfejisi
sağlayıp
örneğin
d-referencing
operatörün
operanda olması
gibi
hem de
aynı zamanda
dinamik ömürlü
nesnelerin
ve kaynakların
yaşam sürelerini
hayatlarını
kontrol etmek
amaçlı
kullanılıyorlarsa
bunlara
smart pointer
demek
yaygın
ben de
tür şeyde
akıllı pointer
terimini
kullanıyorum
birebir
çeviriyorum
Necati
unique
ptr'da
shared ptr'da
ikisi de
smart pointer
sınıfı
ve ikisi de
jenerik
değil mi
kesinlikle
arkadaşlar
yani
unique ptr
sınıfı
bir sınıf
şablonu
shared ptr
sınıfı
bir sınıf
şablonu
arkadaşlar
aralarındaki
önce makro düzeyde
farklılıktan
bahsedelim
unique ptr
sınıfının
içindeki
unique
sözcüğü
eşsiz
tek
benzeri
olmayan
anlamda
değil mi
burada
kastettiği
anlam
arkadaşlar
bir
unique ptr
nesnesinin
bir kaynağa
erişmekte
arkadaşlar
tek nesne
olması
yani
İngilizcesiyle
bir
unique ptr
nesnesinin
yönettiği
hayatını yönettiği
kaynağın
sahibi
durumunda
o yüzden
burada
kullanılan
stratejiye
İngilizce'de
exclusive
ownership
stratejisi de
deniyor
yani
Türkçeye
birebir
çevirirsek
tek
sahiplik
yani
bir nesnenin
bir kaynağın
bir sahibi
olur
ve
o sahip
öldüğünde
biraz dramatik
oldu
o sahibin
hayatı
bittiğinde
o sahip
hayata
veda
ettiğinde
onun yönettiği
kaynakta
geri verilir
böylece
böyle bir
sınıf
türünden
nesneleri
kullanarak
bu nesnelere
kaynak
bağlayabiliyoruz
ama o kaynağı
artık
kendimizin
sonlandırması
örneğin
delete etmesi
gerekmiyor
ne zamanki
pointer
değişkenimizin
akıllı pointer
unique ptr
değişkenimizin
ne zamanki
hayatı
bitecek
o zaman
yönettiği
kaynağı
sonlandıracak
örneğin
delete edecek
ya da özel bir şekilde
sonlandıracak
unique ptr
sınıfı
böyle bir sınıf
ve
arkadaşlar
tek sahiplik
derken
hopyalamaya
karşı
kapatılmış
yani örneğin
rasul
mamadov
arkadaşımdan
bahsediyorum
o bir
unique ptr
nesnesi olsa
necadde bir
unique ptr
nesnesi olsa
benim değerimi
ona
kopyalayamıyorsunuz
kopyalamaya
karşı
kapatılmış
yani
aynı zamanda
iki akıllı
pointer'ın
aynı
nesneyi
göstermesi
mümkün
değil
yani en azından
çok kaba bir
hata yapmazsak
mümkün değil
böylece
arkadaşlar
neden de
emin oluyoruz
elimizde bir
unique ptr
nesnesi varsa
ve bu nesne
bir kaynağı
kontrol ediyorsa
onun
başka bir yerde
o kaynağa
yönelik
örneğin
bizim unique ptr
nesnemiz o kaynağı
geri verdikten sonra
bir
dending pointer
oluşmayacak
ve delete etme
ya da kaynağı
sonlandırmak için
bir fonksiyonun
çağrılması
ihmali
söz konusu
olmayacak
daha da önemlisi
unique ptr'nin
kendisi
gerçek bir pointer
olmadığı için
bir sınıf nesnesi
olduğu için
dinamik ömürlü bir nesnenin
hayatını kontrol etmekte olan
unique ptr'yi
oluşturduktan sonra
bir exception
throw ederse
bu exception
yakalandığında
stack unwinding
daha önce öğrenmiştik
dediğimiz süreç
devreye girdiğinde
stack unwinding
de
otomatik ömürlü
nesneler
destroy edilecek
unique ptr nesnesi
destroy edildiğinde
destraktörü
kaynağı
geri verecek
yani unique ptr nesnesi
akıllı bir şekilde
kendi destraktörü
çağrıldığında
eğer hayatını
kontrol etmekte
olduğu bir kaynak
ya da bir dinamik ömürlü
nesne varsa
ya da bir dinamik ömürlü nesne varsa
onu sonlandırıyor
böylece
ingilizcesiyle
bir exception
safety de
exception
güvenliği de
sağlanmış oluyor
yani
kaynak sızıntısı
riski
ortadan
alkıyor
shape ptr'de
durum farklı
o da akıllı
pointer
o da
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesnenin
ya da bir kaynağın
hayatını kontrol ediyor
ama
kopyalanabiliyor
yani burada
amaç tam tersi
aynı kaynağın
birden fazla
pointer tarafından
gösterilmesi
mümkün
kılınsın
fakat
yine de
kaynağın
sonlandırılması
adeta
otomatik hale getirirsin
işte burada
tahmin edebileceğimiz gibi
reference counting
denilen
Türkçe'ye çevirirsek
referans sayımı
denilen
bir teknik
kullanılıyor
arkadaşlar
yani örneğin
ben
Ahmet
Mehmet
Hasan
Necati Ahmet
Mehmet
Hasan
share ptr
nesneleri ise
aynı
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi gösteriyor
olabilir miyiz
evet
ama
ne zaman ki
örneğin
Necati
kaynağı gösteren
en son
nesne olacak
yani
aynı kaynağı gösteren
diğer nesneler
diğer akıllı
pointerların
hayatı bitmiş
onlar
hayata veda
etmiş olsun
Necati'nin
destraktörü
çağrıldığında
Necati için
destraktörü
çağrıldığında
Necati
kaynağı gösteren
son pointer
değişken olduğunu
anlayacak
ve Necati için
çağrılan
destraktör
kaynağı
geri verecek
adı üstünde
bakın
buradaki
unique
ownership
buradaki
shared
shared ownership
yani
paylaşılan
sahibi
bir nesnenin
bir tane
sahibi olmak
zorunda değil
bir nesnenin
bir tane
iki tane
on tane
yirmi tane
sahibi olabilir
ama
muhikanların
sonuncusu
son sahip
hayata veda
ettiğinde
o kaynağı
geri verecek
arkadaşlar
tipik olarak
şöyle bir
analoji
daha önce de
söylemiş olabilirim
yaygın
kullanılıyor
işte belki
daha önce
kendimi tekrar
etmiş oluyorum
daha önce de
anlatmıştım
muhtemelen
demiştim ki
bir toplantı
salonu var
büyükçe bir salon
içinde küçük küçük
başka odalar da var
arkadaşlar
toplantı
salonunda
efendim
bütün
bu aktivite
bitince
oradaki
bilgisayarların
kapatılması
projektörün
elektriklerin
kapatılması
yapılması
gereken
bir sürü
iş var
ama
bunlar
toplantı
salonu
halen
kullanılmaktaysa
yapılırsa
içeridekiler
mağdur olacak
bu durumda
bu işlemlerin
yapılması için
arkadaşlar
bu işlemi
yapacak
kişinin
toplantı
salonundaki
son kişi
olduğunun
farkına
varması lazım
böylece
toplantı
salondan
çıkmadan
önce
diyecek ki
ben son
kişiyim
ben de çıktığımda
toplantı
salonunda
kimse
kalmayacak
o zaman
ben
hemen
projektörü
kapatacağım
bilgisayarları
şunu bunu
yapacağım
ondan sonra
çıkacağım
ama
bunu
nasıl
anlayacak
işte
bütün bu
toplantı
salonunu
kullanan
kişilere
birer token
versek
bunlar
girişte
tokenı
diyelim ki
bir
kavanozun
içine
bıraksa
çıkışta da
bir token
alsalar
ben
Necati
olarak
toplantı
salondan
çıkma
sürecinde
bir de
bakıyorum ki
kavanozda
bir tane
token
kalmış
herkes
tokenını
aldığına göre
bir tane
token
kaldığına göre
en son
ben kalmışım
toplantı
salonda
son kişi
olduğunu
anlıyorum
sorumluluk
bilinciyle
gidiyorum
bilgisayarları
projektörü
modemi
vesaire
kapatıyorum
işte burada
paylaşılan
sahiplik söz
konusu
arkadaşlar
biz önce
unique
ptr
sınıfını
kullanacağız
şimdi şu
sorunun cevabı
da bence
önemli
unique
ptr
mı
daha sık
kullanılıyor
share
ptr
mı
sizce
tahmin edin
tahmin
sadece
yani
kullanım
yüzdesi
olarak
sizce
hangisi
daha fazla
kullanılıyor
olabilir
arkadaşlar
hayır hayır
share ptr
değil
unique ptr
emin olabilirsiniz
bence
cengizhan
yarı yarıya
da değil
yani
benim
kendi
gözlemim
%75'e
%25 gibi
yani
unique ptr
daha çok
kullanılıyor
arkadaşlar
ama
hangisinde
öğrenecek şey
daha fazla
diye soracak
olursak
share ptr
da bence
daha fazla
yani share ptr
sınıfını
kullanmak
özel durumlarını
üye fonksiyonlarını
şunlarını
bunların
öğrenmek
unique ptr'a
göre
daha zor
yani
ben yine de
küçük bir yanılgı
payı da koyayım
farklı görüşler
geldiği için
bence
unique ptr
kesinlikle
daha fazla
kullanılıyor
bütün
c++
kodlarına
baktığımız zaman
ama
share ptr'ı
öğrenmek
daha zor
daha
zahmetli
işte
burada
bir de
üçüncü bir
sınıf var
demiştik
weak ptr
buradaki
weak biliyorsunuz
ingilizce
zayıf
çelimsiz
güçsüz
anlamında
weak ptr
kendisi doğrudan
bir akıllı
pointer sınıfı
olarak
görünmemeli
share ptr
sınıfının
kullanımıyla
ilgili
ortaya çıkan
bazı
problemli durumların
çözümü için
kullanılan bir sınıf
olduğunu
weak ptr'ın
söyleyebiliriz
evet
dependency
durumları
özellikle
cyclic
dependency
dediğimiz
senaryo
o zaman
arkadaşlar
unique ptr
sınıfını
öğrenmeye
başlayabiliriz
şimdi
önce
makrodüsiyeti
şuraya bir
tekrar edelim
unique ptr
nesnesi
bir
kaynağı
ya da
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesnenin
hayatını
kontrol etmek
için var
ve unique ptr
nesnesi
edindiği
kaynağı
kendi destrakları
çağrıldığında
geri veriyor
artık geri veriyor
derken delete
medyo
bir fonksiyonu
mu çağırıyor
oraya
konuşacağız
unique ptr
bir
sınıf
çablonu
ve
iki
template
parametreli
bir sınıf
çablonu
bakın bir template
parametresi yok
iki template
parametreli
ama daha sonra
göreceğimiz
share ptr
sınıfı
sadece
bir tane
template
parametresine
sahip
unique ptr
sınıfı
şöyle bir sınıf
memoria
başlık
dosyasından
template
type name
t
d
arkadaşlar
ama
ikinci
template
parametresi
daha sonra
çok ayrıntılı
konuşacağız
default
argüman
alıyor
template'lerin
default
argüman
alma
özelliğini
hatırlayalım
ve aldığı
default
argüman
şu
stu
arkadaşlar
default
delete'in
p
açılımı
class
unique
ptr
arkadaşlar
şimdi çok dikkatli
izleyelim
şurayı da düzeltelim
böyle bir sınıftan
bahsediyoruz
tabi ki bu sınıfın
bir interfezi var
ama
aslında
unique ptr
sınıfı
çok zekice
akıllıca
tasarlanmış
aslında
ingilizcesiyle
bir
hint
rapper
yani
güzelliği de burada
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesneyi
bir
raw pointer ile
onun hayatını
kontrol etmekle
bir
unique ptr
nesnesiyle
yani pointer gibi
kullanılacak bir
unique ptr nesnesiyle
hayatını kontrol etmek
arasında
maliyet açısından
çok özel durumları
olmadıkça
bir fark yok
ne
memory
footprint olarak
yani
bellekte kapladığı
yer açısından
ne de
işlem maliyeti
açısından
aslında bir
fark yok
özellikle
derleyicilerin
inline
extension'ı
rahatlıkla
fonksiyonların
kodlarını gördüğü
zaman
yapabilmeleri
ve
derleyicilerin
gerçekten çok iyi
optimizasyon yapan
programlar
olmaları
unique ptr
kullanmakla
arkadaşlar
normal
hand pointer'ları
kullanmak arasında
bellek kullanımı
açısından
ve işlem sayısı
bir maliyet
farkı
olmadığını
tekrar söylüyorum
çok özel durumlar
hariç
söyleyebiliriz
bu yüzden
şu bahaneyi
bahane
tamamen
kaybetmemiz
gerekiyor
aklımızdan
ben
unique ptr
kullanmıyorum
çünkü
maliyeti var
eğer böyle
söylerseniz
kimseyi
inandıramazsınız
dolayısıyla
dinamik ömürlü
nesnelerin
hayatını
biz
default olarak
artık
unique ptr
nesneleriyle
kontrol etmeliyiz
sadece ve sadece
eğer
topyalanmaları
gerekiyorsa
yani aynı zamanda
birden fazla
pointer'ın
aynı kaynağı
göstermesi
sonusuysa
o senaryoda
o zaman
unique ptr
yerine
shared ptr
sınıfını
kullanmayı
düşünebiliriz
necat
dinamik ömürlü
nesnelerin
hayatlarını
kontrol eden
sınıflar
sadece bunlar mı
tabii ki
değil
yani
üçüncü parti
kütüphanelerde
de sınıflar var
ama her zaman
genel ilkemiz ne
standart kütüphane
işimizi görüyorsa
bize yönelik
özel bir problem
çıkartmıyorsa
her zaman
standart kütüphanenin
fonksiyonlarını
tercih etmeliyiz
diyebiliriz
değil mi
ya da sınıfların
arkadaşlar
bakın bakın
bakın
aslında
sınıfın
implementasyonunun
şöyle olduğunu
düşünün
çok basit
bir
tabanıza
canlandırma
sağlayacağım
arkadaşlar
yani burada
aslında böyle
bir pointer
değişken var
gelin buna
mp diyelim
bu pointer
değişken
duruma göre
null pointer
olabilir
yani aslında
unique ptr
bu açıdan
baktığımızda
o terimi
kullanırsak
bir
nullable type
arkadaşlar
unique ptr
sınıfının
a
konstruktörü
ya da daha
sonradan
göreceğimiz
bazı
üye fonksiyonları
bu pointer'ın
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesne
ya da bir
kaynağı
göstermesini
sağlayabilir
örneğin
unique ptr'ın
şöyle bir
konstruktörü
olsun
public
ki gerçekten
var
arkadaşlar
unique
ptr
t
yıldız
p
basit
değiştirilmiş
olarak
yazıyorum
tabi ki
ayrıntılı
göreceğiz
bu
konstruktörde
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesnenin
adresini
alsın
örneğin
niv
ifadesiyle
oluşturulmuş
ve
arkadaşlar
bu pointer'ı
onunla
initialize
etmiş olsun
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
işte
ben
unique
ptr
nesnesine
a oluşturduğunda
ya da
sonra
oluşturduktan
örneğin
sınıfın
daha sonra
göreceğimiz
basitleştirilmiş
yazalım
reset
fonksiyonunu
kullanarak
bir kaynağı
bu şekilde
edilmesini
hayatını
kontrol etmesini
sağlayabiliyoruz
ama
gel
gelelim ki
gelelim
bir de
unique ptr
sınıfının
tabi ki
destruktörü
var
destruktörünün
bunun da
şöyle
olduğunu
düşünün
bir de
unique ptr
arkadaşlar
if
np
null pointer
değilse
kaynağı
geri verecek
ama
şimdi
dikkat
asıl
kritik durum
çok daha
2-3 saat sonra
geri döneceğimiz
kritik yere
şimdi ilk defa
bir temas
edelim
arkadaşlar
bakınız
aslında
buradaki
kod
şöyle
olabilirdi
değil mi
ama
buradaki
kod
böyle
olsaydı
bir
kastimizasyon
imkanı
vermezdi
değil mi
yani
unique ptr'ın
hayatını
kontrol
ettiği
nesneyi
ya da
kaynağı
hayır hayır
Yusuf Furkan
ondan bahsetmiyorum
null pointer
atamaktan
bahsetmiyorum
çok daha
önemli bir
konu
yani
kaynağı
sonlandırma
sadece
delete
ifadesine
bağlanmış
olurdu
değil mi
delete
dışında
başka bir
şansım
olmazdı
şimdi
neden
ikinci
bir template
parametresi
olduğunu
tahmin
edebiliyor
musunuz
arkadaşlar
aslında
bakın
buradaki
kodun
basitleştirilmiş
olarak
yine
şöyle
olduğunu
düşünün
ben
ikinci
template
parametresi
türünden
örneğin
bir geççi
nesne
oluştursam
anlamanızı
kolaylaştırmak
için
yazıyorum
ve
bunun
p
yıldız
parametreli
arkadaşlar
bir
operatör
fonksiyonu
olsa
o zaman
d
türünden
bir nesneyi
fonksiyon
çağrı
operatörünü
operandı
yapabilirim
ve buna
mp
yi
gönderebilirim
şimdi
bu durumda
eğer
burada
çağrılan
fonksiyonun
kodu
delete
mp
ise
pointer
yani
dinamik
ömürünün
nesne
delete
edilecek
ama
başka bir
kod ise
o zaman
o kod
çalışacak
yani
siz
böylece
ikinci
template
parametresine
karşılık
gelen
template
argümanının
default delete
olmasını
sağlarsanız
yani
varsayılan
argümanı
kullanırsanız
arkadaşlar
bakın
default delete'in de
şöyle olduğunu
düşünün
template
pipename
t
arkadaşlar
class
ya da
struct
default delete
bakın bakın
bakın
çok eğlençeli
bu sınıfın
şöyle bir
operatör fonksiyonu
olsun
void
arkadaşlar
yani
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonu
operatör
fonksiyon çağrı
p
yıldız p
arkadaşlar
tahmin edin
kodu
delete p
şimdi bu
noktada
eğer
ikinci
template
parametresi
default delete'in
t açılımıysa
arkadaşlar
default delete'in
t açılımı
ne yapıyor
onun
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonu
t türünden
bir nesnenin
adresini alıyor
ve o pointer'ı
delete ifadesinde
kullanıyor
burayı anladık mı
bu da şu demek
unique ptr nesnesinin
hayatı bittiğinde
siz sadece
hayatını kontrol
ettiği nesnenin
delete edilmesini
istiyorsanız
o zaman
ikinci template
parametresini
arkadaşlar
herhangi bir
şekilde
özel
bir template
argümanı
kullanmak yerine
doğrudan
default delete'i
kullanabilirsiniz
burayı anladık mı
burayı anlamamız
çok önemli
ama bakın
kaynağın
sonlandırılması
delete ifadesiyle
olmayacaksa
o zaman
mecbur
ne yapacaksınız
gideceksiniz
arkadaşlar
ikinci
template
parametresi
yerine
template
argümanı
olarak
kendi
türünüzü
kullanacaksınız
sizin
sağladığınız
fonksiyon
aslında
aldığı
adresteki
nesneyi
delete etmek
yerine
ne gerekiyorsa
onu
yapacak
buraya kadar
anladık mı
arkadaşlar
evet o zaman
hemen
şöyle
bir de
gösterelim
tabii ki
stud namespace
içinde
bakınız
unique
ptr'ın
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
necat
görmedik
birinci
template
parametresi
hayatı
kontrol edilecek
nesnenin
türü
ikinci
template
parametresi
aslında
buna
deleter
deniyor
ingilizce'de
yani
silici
arkadaşlar
yok edici
ikinci
template
parametresi
kaynağın
sonlandırılmasını
aslında
fiilen
gerçekleştiren
sınıf
ki
default
delete'i
seçersek
yani
default template
argümanını
seçersek
delete
etmiş
oluyoruz
sevgili
arkadaşlar
evet evet
o zaman
mesela
şöyle bir sınıf
varsa
class
my class
ve
diyelim ki
ben
dinamik ömürlü
my class
nesnelerinin
hayatını
kontrol etmek
için
bir
unique
ptr
nesnesini
kullanmak
istesem
örneğin
şöyle bir
kod
yazabileceğim
unique
ptr
arkadaşlar
my class
açılımı
dikkat
my class
yıldız
açılımı
değil
tabii ki
my class
açılımı
uptr
ve
new
my class
yanlış anlaşılmasın
böyle
yazabiliriz
anlamda
ama
çoğunlukla
böyle de
yazmayacağız
birazdan
göreceksiniz
böylece
unique
ptr
p
yıldız
parametreli
konstruktörü
gidecek
bu adresi
aslında
private
veri elemanında
saklayacak
o zaman
yavaş yavaş
unique ptr
sınıfını
tanımaya
çalışalım
burada
her
fonksiyonun
zaten çok fazla
üye fonksiyonu
yok
ama her
üye fonksiyonun
her free
fonksiyonun
ayrı bir
önemi var
bir tanesini bile
ihmal
etmememiz
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
önce
şuradan
başlayalım
unique ptr
nesnesi
aslında
sadece
bir pointer
sarmalıyor
yani
unique ptr
sınıfını
bir rapper
olarak
düşünmelisiniz
ve
thin rapper
arkadaşlar
bakın bakın
bunu nasıl
anlayabilirim
son derece
basit
arkadaşlar
iostream
başlık dosyasını
dahil edeyim
ve
örneğin
int
yıldız
türünün
ya da
class
my class
arkadaşlar
yıldız
türünün
size of
değerini
yazdırıyorum
ve ondan
sonra da
bakın
arkadaşlar
bir
using
direktifi
kullanayım
yazımız
kolay olsun
ve
size of
unique ptr'ın
arkadaşlar
int açılımı
yani
binamik ömürlü
int nesnelerin
hayatını
kontrol etmek için
ve aynı şekilde
altına da
unique ptr'ın
my class
specialization'ı
için
size of
değerini
yazdırayım
derliyorum
ve
çalıştırıyorum
arkadaşlar gördüğünüz gibi
4 byte
yani
buraya çok dikkat
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
ben
unique ptr'ın
nesnesine
kullanacağım
önce makro
düzeyde
şurayı
anlatın
sen emin olalım
ve diyelim ki
şöyle bir
kod yazdınız
my class
unique ptr'ın
açılımı
uptr
new
my class
ve
bu da
diyelim ki
bir blok içinde
söyleyin bakalım
uptr'nin
destraktörü
nerede çağrılacak
programın
akışı
onun
skopunun
sonunu
belirleyen
closing
price'e
geldiğinde
bravo
peki
unique ptr'ın
destraktörü
az önce
gördük
ne yapacak
arkadaşlar
aslında
kendi
veri elemanı
olan
pointer'ı
delete
ifadesinin
operanda
yapacak
bunu doğrudan
yapmıyor
nasıl yaptığını
gösterdim
ikinci template
parametresiyle
ama
kritik nokta
burada şu
sonra dönüp
dolaşıp
buraya geleceğiz
kritik nokta
şu
artık ben
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
delete etmiyorum
ne zaman ki
uptr'nin
hayatı
bitti
dinamik ömürlü
nesne
delete
edecek
bu bir
ikincisi
burada
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
bir fonksiyon
çağırıldı
şimdi
soru
a
bu fonksiyonun
kodunun
çalışmasında
runtime'da
exception
throw etmedi
o zaman
programın
akışı
buraya gelecek
ve
ilerleyecek
burada
uptr'nin
destraktörü
çağıracak
uptr'nin
destraktörü
14.
satırda
nev ifadesiyle
oluşturulmuş
myclass
nesnesini
delete
edecek
ama
bu fonksiyonu
exception
throw ederse
bu exception
yakalandığında
exception
handle edildiğinde
handle edilmeden
programın akışı
catch blow'una
girmeden
stack
unwinding
dediğimiz
süreçle
otomatik
ömürlü
sınıf
nesnelerinin
yani
uptr'e
dahil
destraktörü
çağırılacak
yani bu ne demek
exception
gönderilerek
bu koddan
çıkılsa da
exception
gönderilmeden
normal yolda
çıkılsa da
arkadaşlar
uptr'nin
destraktörü
çağırılacak
ya
hayatı
bittiği için
çağırılacak
ya da
stack unwinding
sürecinde
çağırılacak
böylece
kaynağın
geri verilmesi
garanti altına
alınmış
olacak
orayı anladık mı
arkadaşlar
önce
çok basit
nelerle
başlayalım
via fonksiyonlarla
bir
default
constructor
unique
vtr
nesneleri
default
constructible
yani pekala
şöyle bir
unique
vtr
nesnesi
oluşturabilirsiniz
unique
vtr
my
class
up
burada
bir kaynağı
kontrol etmiyor
dinamik ömürlü bir nesnenin
hayatını kontrol etmiyor
örneğin
gelin buna
empty state
diyelim
yani boş durumda
gördüğümüz gibi
bir unique
vtr
nesnesi
burada
empty
terimini
ben kullanıyorum
yani
api'nin
ismi
değil
api'nin
ismi
değil
ya
hayattadır
ve bir kaynağı
kontrol ediyor
durumdadır
stektedir
ya da
hayattadır
ama
hiçbir
kaynağı
kontrol etmiyordur
arkadaşlar
hayattaysa
bizi o kaynağı
eriştirecek
yani
up
hayattaysa
ve bir kaynağı
kontrol ediyorsa
bizi o kaynağı
eriştirecek
sunduğu api'ler
eğer hayattaysa
ve bir kaynağı
kontrol etmiyorsa
bize
bunu
sorgulama imkanı
da verecek
yani
ben
up'nin
halen
bir kaynağı
kontrol eden
state de olup
olmadığını
test edebilirim
arkadaşlar
nasıl test edeceğim
önce oradan
başlayalım
test etmek için
birden fazla
fonksiyon
ya da
yapı
kullanabilirim
ama
şimdi
en basiti
tahmin edebildiğiniz
gibi
operatör
arkadaşlar
bool
fonksiyonu
hayır hayır
yusuf
expert
fonksiyonu
burada
böyle bir fonksiyon
yok
neyle karıştırıyor
olabilirsiniz
weak ptr
sınıfıyla
karıştırıyor
olabilirsiniz
yani burada
if up
demek
daha önce
çeşitli örnekleri
gördük
up'nin
arkadaşlar
operatör
bool
fonksiyonunun
çağrılması
demek
demek ki
boş mu
bir nesnenin
hayatını kontrol ediyor
mu
etmiyor mu
operatör
bool
fonksiyonuyla
sınayabiliriz
ama tek sınavla
yolu bu
değil
diğerlerini de
göreceğiz
ama ilk olarak
bunu
gösterelim
ama bakın
biraz daha
ifadeyi
basitleştireceğim
çünkü bundan sonra
kodlarda
çok sık
kullanacağım
şöyle bir
deyim
yazacağım
boş olup
olmadığını
size
göstermek
için
iostream
başlık dosyası
dahil edilmiş
cout
arkadaşlar
izleyin
up
ben hangi
nesneden
bahsettiğimi
yazacağım
törner
operatör
burada da
lojik yorumlanma
söz konusu
olduğundan
operatör
bool
fonksiyonu
çağrılacak
arkadaşlar
hadi gelin
buna
dolu
diyelim
ve diğerine
boş
diyelim
normalde bu terim
kullanılmıyor
bunu ben kullanıyorum
bakınız
default
construct edilmiş
bir
unique
ptr
nesnesi
boş
oysa
eğer
bir kaynağın
kontrolünü
üstlenmişse
hadi öyle bir örnek
verelim
new my class
o zaman
boş mu
dolu mu
sorgulaması
yaptığımda
dolu olacak
arkadaşlar
yalnız
iki nedenle
boş olabilir
birincisi
default
construct edilmiştir
o yüzden
boştur
yani az önceki örnek
ama başka
senaryolar da var
ilerleyen dakikalarda
göreceğiz
başta
doludur
ama
mülkiyeti
yani
hayatını kontrol
ettiği
nesnenin
sahibi ya
ben ona
mülkiyet diyorum
mülkiyeti
başka bir
unique ptr
nesnesine
devretmiş olabilir
çünkü
birazdan göreceğimiz
gibi
unique ptr
nesneleri
kopyalamaya karşı
kapalı
ama taşımaya
karşı açık
yani
necati bir
unique ptr
nesnesi
yusuf da
bir unique ptr
nesnesi
kaynağın
sahibi
necati
ama
necati'den
kaynak
yusuf'a
aktarılabilir
yusuf bu
aktarımdan önce
empty state
ise
yani boş
o zaman
dolu hale
gelecek
ama
kaynağı
çalınmış
olan
necati de
boş
hale gelecek
ya da
başka bir
ihtimal
unique ptr
nesnesinin
kendi
hayatı
devam
ederken
bir taşıma
da söz
konusu
değilken
biz
yine
sınıfın
sağladığı
birden fazla
API ile
hayatını
kontrol ettiği
nesnenin
destroy edilmesini
kaynağın
sonlandırılmasını
sağlayabiliriz
dolayısıyla
hayata
boş geldiği için
boş olabilir
ama
doludur
ama sonradan
ya
mülkiyeti
başka bir
unique ptr
nesnesine
aktardığı için
ya da
kaynağı
kendi
sonlandırdığı için
boş
duruma
geçebilir
arkadaşlar
hatta bakın
şimdi erken
olsa da
birkaç tane
API göstereyim
up eşittir
null ptr
arkamda
söylemiştim
nullable bir
type olduğunu
arkadaşlar
sınıfın
null ptr
underscore t
türünden
atom operatör
fonksiyonu
var
bu atom operatör
fonksiyonu
ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
nesnenin
destroy edilmesini
sağlıyor
eğer dolu
durumdaysa
boşa çıkacak
ama burada
kaynağı da
sonlandıracak
ya da
bunu yapmanın
farklı yolları
da var
örneğin
reset
fonksiyonuna
argüman
göndermezseniz
yani default
argümanı
kullanırsanız
yine
hayatını
arkadaşlar
sonlandırmış
olacaksınız
ya da
yine
ilerleyen dakikalarda
gördüğümüz
release
isimli
fonksiyonu
çağırarak
kaynağı
destroy
etmesini
delete
etmesi
yerine
sadece
sahipliği
bırakmasını
geri dönüş
değeriyle
hayatını
kontrol
ettiği
nesnenin
adresine
döndürmesini
sağlayabilirsiniz
o zaman
tekrar edelim
operatör
boğul
fonksiyonumuz
var
fakat sadece
operatör
boğul
fonksiyonu
değil
arkadaşlar
boş mu
dolu mu
olduğunu
anlamanın
bir bakka
yolu da
doğrudan
null
ptr'la
karşılaştırmak
demek ki
null
ptr'la
karşılaştırmayı
sağlayan
null
ptr
render score
t parametreli
bir
eşit eşit
ve eşit
değil
karşılaştırma
fonksiyonları
var
yani
örneğin
if
up
eşit
değil
null ptr
böyle
yazarsak
ipin
doğru kısmına
girerse
dolu olduğunu
anlayacağız
şimdilik ben
boş dolu
terimlerini
kullanıyorum
biraz rahatsız
olsada
else
boş
derliyorum
şu anda
dolu
ama
default
masraf
deseydim
boş
birunda
olacaktı
arkadaşlar
buraya dikkat
eğer
dinamik ömürlüğü
nesnenin
ya da
kaynağın
kendisine
erişmek
istersek
son derece
basit
içerik
operatör
fonksiyonu
yani
dereferencing
operatör
fonksiyonu
var
yani
up
isimli
değişken
bir
unique
ptr
nesnesi
ise
yıldız
up
onun
gösterdiği
nesne
yani
hayatını
kontrol
ettiği
nesne
yine
sınıfın
ok
operatör
fonksiyonu
arrow
operator
function
hayatını
kontrol
ettiği
nesnenin
öğelerine
erişmek
için
kullanılabilir
yani
up
ok
fu
ya da
up
ok
bar
ya da
eğer bir
data member
söz konusuysa
up ok
mx
biçiminde
nesnenin
yani
hayatı kontrol
edilen nesnenin
öğelerine
erişebilirim
bu da
pointer gibi
kullanılabileceğini
gösteriyor
değil mi
arkadaşlar
bundan sonraki
örneklerin
anlaşılması
için
basit bir
sınıf
yazacağız
birlikte
çok çok
basit bir
sınıf
merak etmeyin
hem de
header only
library
olsun
yani örneklerde
konuyu
daha iyi
anlamanızı
sağlamak için
ben bu sınıfın
ismini
point
diyeceğim
yani
olabilecek en basit
sınıflardan biri
bakın
class
point
private
içinde
default
member
inçalar
olsun
sınıfın
public
bölümü
bir
default
constructor
olsun
default
edinmiş
olsun
default
bildirimi
olsun
arkadaşlar
hatta
bundan da
vazgeçtim
izleyin
parostream
başlık dosyası
normalde
yapmayın
tabi
başlık
dosyasını
include
ediyorum
see out
point
this
eşittir
sınıfı
bir de
destructor
yazıyorum
gerekmese de
tabi
kill the
point
önce
default
constructor
ya da
destructor
çağrıldığında
arkadaşlar
haberimiz olacak
3 parametre gibi
constructor veriyorum
point
int x
int y
int z
bunun içine
de
yine
şimdilik
çağrıldığını
gösteren
bir statement
koyalım
gösterecek olan
arkadaşlar
buraya kadar
bir hata
olmadığından
emin olalım
evet ve
devam edelim
bir tane de
bir iki tane de
üye fonksiyon koyalım
mesela
void
set
int
x
int y
int z
mx eşittir
x
m y
m y eşittir
y
m z eşittir
z
en azından bir tane get fonksiyonumuz olsun
int
get x
arkadaşlar
const
return
mx
bu kadar yeter
bir de
inserter
o stream inserter
bir yazacağım
stok
o stream
red
operatör
left shift
stok
o stream
ref
os
const
point
ref
p
friend
hidden friend
ve
fonksiyonumuzun
kodu
return
os
aç parantez
p.mx
virgül boşluk
p.my
virgül
boşluk
p.mz
kapanan
parantez
olsun
buraya kadar
kodu
test edelim
çok basit
bir şekilde
point
başlık
dosyasını
ekliyorum
ve
örneğin
point
türünden
p1
p2
siyahat
p1
p2
set
arkadaşlar
siyahat
p1
vesaire
evet
çalıştıralım
arkadaşlar
evet bakın
bir problem
yok
her şey yolunda
peki
şimdi
yavaş yavaş
artık
kodlarımızı
yazmaya
başlayalım
arkadaşlar
önce
şu
destraktörün
nesnenin
hayatını
sonlandırması
kısmına
bir bakalım
mesela
void
bu
arkadaşlar
stud
unic ptr
up
new
point
açılımı
tabi
türeş
ismi
kullanmak
çok yaygın
söylemeye
gerek yok
bakın
uyu
çağırıyorum
buraya
main
is
still
running
böyle bir
statement
koyayım
neyi
göstermek
için
arkadaşlar
bu
fonksiyonun
closing
price'ine
programına
bir şey
geldiğinde
bu
nesnemiz
ne olacak
delete
edilecek
bakın
burada
dinamik öbürlüğü
nesneni yarattım
ve delete
ediyorum
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
main
is
still
running
den önce
destructorın
çağrıldığını
görüyorsunuz
şimdi bir iki tane
özel not
arkadaşlar
bir
az önce söylediğim gibi
unique
ptr
nesnesi
dolu olmak
zorunda
değil
iki
arkadaşlar
t yıldız
parametreli
constrachtörü
var
en sık
kullanılan
constrachtör
işte
dokuzuncu
satırda
çağırdığım
constrachtör
fakat bu
explicit
constrachtör
konusunu
kursun başlarında
görmüştük
yani örneğin
şöyle yazarsam
arkadaşlar
sentaks
hatası
olmasının
nedeni
constrachtörün
explicit
olması
dolayısıyla
bu
constrachtörü
bu şekilde
kullanamayız
bu
hangi durumlar
içinde
geçerli
bakınız
o an
arkadaşlar
bir fonksiyonun
parametresi
örneğin
unique
ptr'ın
point
açılımı
türündense
bu fonksiyona
çağrı
yaparken
çağrıda
örneğin
doğrudan
new ifadesini
kullanabilir miyim
new
point
cevap
hayır
neden
çünkü
constrachtör
explicit
yine benzer
şekilde
bu sefer
bir fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
türlü
arkadaşlar
unique
ptr
türü
ise
örneğin
bu fonksiyonun
içinde
bir return
ifadesi
şöyle
olabilir mi
return
new
point
olamaz
yine burada
sentaks
hatası
olmasının
nedeni
konstrachtörün
explicit
olması
burası
önemli
ama tabi
gerekiyor da
çünkü
yanlışlıkla
böyle bir
atama
nesne
oluşturma
söz konusu
olmasın
diye
zaten
genel
tavsiye
hep ne
arkadaşlar
nereye
baksanız
bu
tavsiyeyi
görüyorsunuz
eğer
konstrachtörün
explicit
olmasını
özellikle
istemiyorsanız
o zaman
explicit
olmasın
ama
default durum
konstrachtörün
özellikle
tek parametreli
konstrachtörlerin
her zaman
explicit
olması
istem dışı
yanlışlıkla yapılan
örtülü
dönüşümlerin
engellenmesi
için
şimdi geldik
önemli bir başka
noktaya
arkadaşlar
yine
bir
unique
ptr
nesnesi
oluşturalım
ama bakın
hayatının
başladığı
ve bittiği
noktayı
yine göstereceğim
main
has
just
started
running
böyle bir
yazı
çıksın
sonra buraya
bir blok
koyalım
ve
yine
unic ptr'nin
point açılımı
birazdan bunun için
türeş ismi de
kullanacağım
uptr
niv
point
takip edin
arkadaşlar
içerik operatör fonksiyonu
ve o
operatör fonksiyonu var
işte
pointer like
interfejsi
bunlar sağlıyor
dolayısıyla
bakınız
örneğe
see out
yıldız
uptr
aslında
yıldız
uptr
yazmak
yusuf
hurkan
neye karşılık
geliyor
tabi ki
uptr'nin
operatör
yıldız
fonksiyonu
yapılan
çare
yani
biz yıldız
uptr
yazdığımızda
bu fonksiyonu
çağırmak
oluyoruz
ister ismiyle
çağırın
ister bu
şekilde
çağırın
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
ya da şuna
ne dersiniz
ister şöyle
yazın
parantez
içinde
yıldız
uptr
set
ya da daha doğal
görünecek şekilde
uptr
ok
set
yani hem
içerik operatörü
hem ok operatörü
d-referensik operatörü
ve arrow operatörleri
gördüğümüz gibi
overload edilmiş durumda
arkadaşlar
yalnız
aman dikkat
aman ki aman
boşken
d-referensi operatörünü
ya da arrow operatörünü
kullanmanız
yani bu operatör fonksiyonlarını
çağırmanız
bir exception
throw etmiyor
yani koda bakın şimdi
açık açık burada gösterelim
artık
scope'u
anladık
unicbtr
point
sizde de oluyor mu
böyle mesela
birine bir şey anlatırken
aslında ben şöyle
yazmak istemiştim
new point
2 4 6
ama yanlışlıkla
işte type oldu
2 4 3 6 oldu
kendim kendime
şöyle diyorum
bu nesnenin
kısmeti buymuş
kısmetine
dokunmak olmaz
o zaman
2 4 3 6
şeklinde kalsın
evet
bakınız
şimdi dinamik ömürlü
bir neyiz
bu kanun efendi oluyor
evet
arkadaşlar
ama
iyi sayın
buraya bir
try bloğu koyalım
ve bir exception gönderilirse
yakalamaya çalışalım
burada zaten
exception gönderilmeyecek
çünkü dolu
yani
zaten bir problem yok
exception gönderilmeyecek
derken
ama bakınız
eğer boşken
bir referencing
operatörünü
çağırırsanız
onu da göstereceğim
yine exception gönderilmeyecek
eğer exception gönderilseydi
gönderilen exception
zaten exception
standart kütüphanemizin
exception yerarşisinden
olacaktı
ve bu exception'i
yakalayacaktık
ama
programın akışının
catch bloğuna
girmemesinden
exception'in
gönderilmediğini
anlıyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
takip edebildik mi
yani
bu
kesinlikle
tanımsız davranış
o zaman
günün önemli
saptamalarından biri
boş bir
unique
ptr nesnesini
bir referans ederseniz
arkadaşlar
uptr
ok
set
üç
beş
sekiz
tanımsız
davranıştır
bir exception
prove etmez
bu da ne demek
arkadaşlar
içerik operatör fonksiyonunu
ya da ok operatör fonksiyonunu
kullandığınız zaman
ya dolu olduğundan
emin olacaksınız
ya da
sınama yaparak
kullanacaksınız
yani örneğin
şöyle bir kod olsaydı
burada
diyelim ki
boş mu dolu mu oldu
aradaki kodlara bağlı
siz burada
şöyle bir kod
yazabilirsiniz
if up
artık try bloğunu da
kaldırayım
nasıl exception
prove etmediğini
biliyoruz
if uptr
ya da
eşit değil
null pointer
önce dolu olduğundan
emin olduğunuzda
ne yapmış
oluyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
içerik operatörünü
d-referencing
operatörünü
ya da o
çağırıyorsunuz
o operatör fonksiyonunu
arkadaşlar
şimdi çok dikkatli
izleyelim
burası
biraz kafa
karıştırıcı
şimdi
soru
diyelim ki
benim bir
unik bir ihtiyar
nestem var
yine eski koda
geri dönelim
unik bir ihtiyarın
point
açılımı
türünden
bir nestem var
şöyle bir kod
yazabilir miyim
uptr
eşittir
niv
tahmin etmeye çalışırım
bilenler değil
tahmin edenler
söylesin
niv
point
yani
acaba
unik bir ihtiyar
sınıfının
t yıldız
t star
parametreli
bir
atom operatör
fonksiyonu
var mı
sizce
tahmin edenler
bilenler
cevap
hayır
hayır hayır
bakın bakın
bir şey yanlış
anlıyorsunuz
verilen cevapların
çoğu yanlış
neden
arkadaşlar
sizce bu kodun
copy
constructor'ın
dirilt edilmesiyle
bir alakası
olabilir mi
cevap
hayır
neden
e çünkü
burası
unik ptr
değil ki
nesnesine
arkadaşlar
başka bir
unik ptr
nesnesine
atamıyorum
dolayısıyla
copy
constructor'la
move
doğrudan
bir alakası
yok
burayı
anladık mı
örtülü
dönüşüm
de yok
burada
vurgulamak
istediğim
böyle bir
atama
operatör
fonksiyonu
yok
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani
unik ptr
nesnesini
hayata
getirirken
dinamik
ömürlü bir
nesnenin
adresine
geçebilirsiniz
constructor'a
çağrı
kağan
ama
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesnenin
adresine
doğrudan
unik ptr
nesnesine
atayamazsınız
ama
işte
bunu yapan
bir fonksiyon
var
aman
buraya
dikkat
bu fonksiyonun
ismi
reset
eğer
sınıfın
reset
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsanız
reset
fonksiyonu
şöyle kafamızda
canlandıralım
demin bir yere
yazmıştık ya
şöyle bir
arkadaşlar
neredeydi o
bulamadım
ama
evet
peki
şurada
gösterelim
class
şöyle olduğunu düşünün
template
type name t
bu sefer kaybetmeyelim
ikinci template
argümanını
şimdilik yazmıyorum
class
unik ptr
işte burada
private
veri elemanı
t yıldız
mp
burası
public
interfezi
şimdi dikkatli
bakın bir daha
şöyle bir fonksiyon
var mı
unik ptr
p
yıldız
cevap var
bu fonksiyon
eksplisit mi
arkadaşlar
evet
ama
şöyle bir fonksiyon
var mı
operatör
otomat
t yıldız
hayır
böyle bir fonksiyon
yok
yusuf anlaşıldı mı
çar anlaşıldı mı
e çar zaten
yok bence
demiş
yanlış kişiye soruyor
ama bakın
şöyle bir fonksiyon
var
void
reset
arkadaşlar
unik ptr
t yıldız
üstelik bu fonksiyonun
default argümanı var
o da
null ptr
yani
siz
a
bir unik ptr
nesnesine
boş
hayata
getirmişseniz
ya da o boş
stedde ise
daha sonra
onu
dolu hale
getirmek
istiyorsanız
bunun yollarından
biri
arkadaşlar
sınıfın
reset fonksiyonuna
dinamik ömürlü bir
nesnenin
adresine
geçmek
örneğin
niv
point
iki
beş
yedi
takip edebildik mi
buraya kadar
evet
ama bakın
çok dikkatli izleyin
eğer böyle yazmak yerine
reset'i
bu şekilde
çağırırsanız
yani
argüman göndermeden
çağırırsanız
aslında bu
reset'e
null pointer
atamak demek
yani
reset'e
null pointer
göndermek
demek
yani
o pointer'ı
null pointer
yapmak
demek
bu durumda
aman dikkat
birazdan göstereceğim
reset
çağrısı
yapıldığında
zaten
bir nesneyi
göstermekteyse
onun
hayatını
sonlandıracak
yeni
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin
mülkiyetini
alacak
eğer boş
durumdaysa da
dolu duruma
geçecek
gelin bunu bir
gösterelim
bakın
ilk örneğimizde
arkadaşlar
arada da
şu kodları
yazacağım
yine
stia
uptr
arkadaşlar
dolu
üç oldu
ama
boş
uptr
dedik
doğru işareti
yani
turner
operatör
ve şimdi bakın
uptr
reset
ondan sonra
yine bu
statement'ı
yazıyorum
arkadaşlar
şimdi boşken
dolu hale geldi
hatta
uptr
bu birinci örnek
herkes dikkat
izlesin
uptr
boş
arkadaşlar
dolu hale geldi
ve
ona
yeni bir
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin adresi
verdik
ama şöyle
olsaydı
unic ptr
uptr
new
point
arkadaşlar
bakın
şu anda dolu durumda
ama resetle ona yeni bir adres verdiğimde
eski nesneyi destroy edecek
yeni nesnenin
arkadaşlar
mülkiyetini
üstlenecek
ve lütfen bakınız
özellikle
şurada durdurmak istiyorum
void
studgetcar
bakın şimdi
point sınıfının
konstruktörü
çağrıldı
default
konstruktör
uptr
dolu
ama 3 parametreli
konstruktör
çağrıldı
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
buradaki
dis pointerı
yukarıdaki
yani
ilk nesne
bu durumda
delete edildi
ama
uptr
yine dolu
şimdi ben bir tuşa
bastığımda
buradan
çalışmaya devam
edecek
ve bu kez
uptr'nin
kendi
destruktörü
çağrıldığında
yine
nesneyi
delete edecek
Yusuf Furkan
hocam ben bunu
anlamadım
reset
sahipliği
verdiği yeni
nesne ile
yine smart pointer
olması gerekmez mi
ben
sorunuzu
anlayamadım
ama cevabı
sorunuzun muhtemelen
cevabını
söyleyeyim
arkadaşlar
resetin
ne yaptığını
yanlış anlamış
olabilirsiniz
bakınız
soru
siz şimdi
Yusuf
er bir soruya
cevap vermeye
çalışın
soru
uptr
reset
ya da
uptr
reset
null pointer
bu çağrılardan
herhangi
sadece
Yusuf Bey için
değil
bütün
arkadaşlarıma
soruyorum
bu çağrılardan
herhangi birini
yaparsam
ne olacak
son derece
basit
doluysa
boş hale
geçecek
yani hayatını
kontrol etmekte
olduğu nesneyi
delete edecek
Yusuf sizde
söyleyeyim
buraya kadar
anlaşıldı mı
boşsa da
herhangi bir şekilde
bir etkisi
olmayacak
ama şimdi
ikinci soru
arkadaşlar
uptr
reset
diyelim ki
niv
myclass
buradaki
o ptr
myclass
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesnenin
hayatını
kontrol edecek
yani
unique ptr'ın
myclass
açılımı
soru
uptr
boşsa
ne olacak
cevap
dolu hale
gelecek
ve hangi
nesnenin
hayatını
kontrol etmeye
başlayacak
burada oluşturulan
dinamik ömürlüğü
nesnenin
Yusuf
anlaşıldı mı
evet
ama
Yusuf
bakınız
eğer burada
zaten
uptr
doluysa
siz
böyle bir
reset
çağrısı
yaptığınızda
dolu olması
bir nesnenin
hayatını
kontrol etmekte
olduğu değil
o nesneyi
dilit edecek
ama
bu sefer
bu nesnenin
hayatını
kontrol etmeye
başlayacak
yani
adeta
hayatını
kontrol ettiği
nesnenin
dilit edilmesini
ama
unique ptr'ımızın
başka
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesneyi
göstermesini
sağlıyoruz
anlaşıldı mı
evet
peki
o zaman
tam da
ara verme zamanı
saat 21.10
21.30'da
devam edeceğiz
arkadaşlar
unique ptr nesnesini
boş hale getirmenin
birden fazla
yolu var
yani
doluyken
boş hale getirmenin
onların hepsini
isterseniz
önce bir
listeleyelim
bir kısmını
konuştuk
konuşmadık
arkadaşlar
bir
başta da
söylediğim gibi
sınıfın
reset fonksiyonunu
argüman göndermeden
çağırmak
zaten bu fonksiyonun
default argümanı
null ptr
ve
görün bakın
doluyken
boş hale
geldiğini
birlikte
gözlemleyelim
closing price
koyalım
evet
iki
bilen
null ptr
argümanını
geçmek
üç
arkadaşlar
null ptr
atamak
yani
null ptr
underscore
t türünden
neyi
kullanmak
atama
operatör
fonksiyonunu
çağır yapmak
arkadaşlar
peki
şöyle yazsam
bakınız
default
construct edilmiş
bir nesneyi
atasam
yani
unique
btr
point
açılımı
izleyin
e
birazdan göreceğiz
bu bir sağ taraf değeri olduğuna göre
bunun atanması demek
bu da boş olduğuna göre
boş olması demek
peki bunu böyle yazmakla
bunlar fonksiyon
jenerik sınıfı olduğu için
şöyle yazmak arasında
bir fark yok
bu da
yine doluyken
boş hale getiriş
yani bu kodlardan
hangisini görmüş olursanız
olun
unique ptr
nesnesini
doluyken
boş hale getirmenin
her biri
farklı
yolları
ama sonuç
aynı
unique ptr
nesneleri
arkadaşlar
kopyalamaya karşı
kapalı
ama
taşımaya karşı
açık
yani
sınıfın
copy
konstruktörü
ve copy
assignment'ı
delete edilmiş
ama
move
konstruktörü
ve move
assignment
var
önce
kopyalamaya karşı
kapalı olduğunu
bir gösterelim
up1
arkadaşlar
şu kodların
hepsi
sentaks hatası
değil mi
auto
up2
eşittir
up1
sentaks hatası
olmasının nedeni
burada çağrılan
copy
konstruktörün
delete edilmiş
olması
yani gördüğümüz gibi
derleyicimiz
delete edilmiş
bir fonksiyona
çağrı yapıldığı için
sentaks hatası
olduğunu söylüyor
ama
örneğin
up2
nesnesi
hayatta
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
unique
ptr
point
up2
ve
up1
atasaydım
yine
sentaks hatası
olacaktı
bu kez de
delete edilmiş
copy
assignment
fonksiyonuna
çağrıldığı için
sentaks hatası
olacak
fakat
sınıf
tipik olarak
taşıma
semantiğinden
faydalanan
bir yapıya
sahip
yani
move
konstruktörü
var
ve move
assignment
var
arkadaşlar
move
konstrukt ettiğimiz
zaman
örneğin
bu sefer
gönderilen
argümanı
sağ taraf
değeri
yapalım
arkadaşlar
stud move
up1
bu durumda
diğer nesnenin
kaynağını
çalacak
artık
dinamik ömürlü
0 0 0
değerindeki
point nesnesinin
sahibi
up2
olacak
up1
de
boşa
çıkacak
yani
az önceki
odada
orayı bir
kopyalayalım
artık
orayı silmeyelim
evet
bakın
ikinci
bir nesne oluşturuyorum
otu
uptr
buna da
uptr 1
diyelim bari
eşittir
stud move
uptr
şimdi
uptr 1
boşa çıktı
çünkü
kaynağını
diğer nesneye
verdi
uptr 2
dolu
bu şu demek
bir
unique
ptr nesnesini
başka bir
unique ptr nesnesiyle
hayata getirmek
isterseniz
ona ilk değerini
verecek olan
ifade
bir
r value
expression
olmalı
r value
expression
olması
demek
yani sağ taraf
değeri olması
demek
ya bir
geçiş nesne
olacak
formunda
ya isimlendirilmiş
bir nesne ise
stud move'a
argüman olarak
gönderilmiş
olacak
ya da bir
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
olacak
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
şunların hepsi
taşıma semantiği
değil mi
izleyin
bir örnek verelim
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
şöyle bir fonksiyon
olsa
unique
unique ptr'ın
point açılımı
bind sınıftan örnek
veriyorum
arkadaşlar
full fonksiyonu
stud
unique ptr'ın
point açılımı
parametresi
return
up
bakın şimdi
çok dikkatli
nesneye
unique ptr
point açılımı
up
near
point
u'yu
böyle çağırsaydım
sentax hatası olurdu
kopyalamaya karşı
kapatılmış olduğu için
arkadaşlar
çağrı birazdan cevap vereyim
sorunuzu
ama şöyle çağırırsam
çağırırsam
more up
sentax hatası yok
şimdi bakın buraya taşındı
yani
fonksiyonun parametresi için
more constructor
çağırıldı
burada
otomatik ömürlü bir nesne olduğu için
yine
arkadaşlar
l value to x value
x value dönüşümü olacak
conversion olacak
ve yine fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri
unique ptr
türünden olduğu için
taşıma
otomatik olarak
devreye girecek
yani
örneğin şöyle bir kod yazsam
ki
bu kalıba
İngilizce'de
past through diyorlar
tabi burada bir takım kodlar olacak
muhtemelen
arkadaşlar
hiçbir sentax hatası yok
sahibi up
boşa düşmekten
sonra cevap vereyim dedim
ama hemen cevap vereyim
boşa düşmekten
kast edilen
bir nesnenin hayatını
kontrol etme
durumundayken
hiçbir nesnenin hayatını
kontrol etmiyor
yani null ptr durumunda
yani null ptr'la
kıyasladığımda
karşılaştırdığımda
eşitlik karşılaştırılmasında
true olacak
yani
sarmaladığı pointer'ın
değeri null pointer olacak
boşa düşmekten
kasıt bu
anlaşıldı mı
çağrı
şimdi bakın
bir
unique ptr'nin
boş olması demek
şu pointer'ın
null pointer olması demek
peki ne zaman
bu pointer null pointer
default construct edilmişse
ya da
kaynağını başka
bir nesneye vermişse
yani örneğin
siz şimdi
şöyle bir atama yaptığınızda
up2
eşittir up1
her ikisi de
aynı türden
unique ptr nesneleriyse
burada
syntax hatası olurdu
ama
böyle yazarsak
bu nesne
arkadaşlar
şu anda
doluydu
ama
up2
oluştururken
atama yaparken
move assignment
fonksiyonu
çağrıldı
move assignment
fonksiyonu
up2'nin
pointer'ını
set etti
ama up1'in
pointer'ını da
null pointer yaptı
çağrı
anladınız mı
evet
yani
kaynağın sahibi
up1
iken
kaynağın sahibi
up2 oldu
up1
boş
duruma geçti
boş durumda olması
hiçbir nesnenin hayatını kontrol etmediği anlamında
yani
sarmaladığı
rapid
diye
null pointer olması
demek
anlaşıldı mı
evet
peki
o zaman
internet problemimiz varmış
o yüzden sormuş arkadaşım
buraya geri dönelim
taşıma semantiğinden
faydalanıyor
ama
kopyalamaya karşı
kapatılmış
peki
şöyle bir durum olursa
ne olacak
lütfen
buraya da
dikkatli izleyin
şöyle bir durum olursa
ne olacak
diyelim ki elimde
bir unique ptr nesnesi var
unique ptr
yine point
up1
new point
ama elimde bir başka unique ptr nesnesi daha var
up2
point
diyelim ki
2-6-8
çağrı özellikle bu soruya cevap vermeye çalışın
up1
eşittir
arkadaşlar
sput
move
up2
yiçsiz cevap verin soruya
bu durumda ne olacak
up1'e
up2'yi taşıdığım için
up1 önce
kaynağını sonlandıracak
yani
reset fonksiyonu adeta çağrılacak
böylece
burada
0-0-0 değerindeki point nesnesi destroy edilecek
ama
diğerinin kaynağını çalacak
yani
bu durumda up1
doluydu
ama
buradaki
yaratılan nesnenin hayatını kontrol ediyordu
bu atamadan sonra
yine dolu
ama bu nesneyi destroy etti
delete etti
up2'nin
gösterdiği
nesnenin sahibi
durumuna düştü
up2'de tabii ki
boş hale geldi
git burada anlamadığımız bir şey var mı
evet
burada
up2'nin
dolu mu boş mu olduğunu
test etsem
up2 boş durumda
değil mi
ama up1
dolu durumda
buraya
bir get card çağrısı koysam
get card çağrısına gelmeden
destraktörün çağrıldığını
görecek miyim
cevap
evet
çünkü neden
şurada
up1'in
göstermekte olduğu
şu nesne
delete edilmiş olacak
taşımanın ne anlama geldiğini anladık mı
eğer
unique ptr nesnesini
başka bir unique ptr nesnesine taşırsam
artık diyor ki
ben
o nesnenin sahibi değilim
yeni sahibi
atamanın
ya da taşımanın
yapıldığı
nesne
son derece
basit
arkadaşlar
bu da şu demek
örneğin
parametre değişkeni
unique ptr olan
bir fonksiyona
bir unique ptr nesnesi
gönderirseniz
burada
bu çağrıda
argüman olarak
kullanılan
nesnenin
yani bu fonksiyonun
örneğin şöyle çağrıldığını
düşünün
fu
uptr
bu fonksiyon
çalıştığında
parametre değişkenine taşıma yapılacak
dolayısıyla
uptr
kaynağını
bırakmış
boşa çıkmış
ama fonksiyonun
parametre değişkeni de
o kaynağı
tabi burada
move ifadesini
yazmayı
unutmayalım
o kaynağı
edinmiş olacak
bu sağ taraf değeri
olduğu için
arkadaşlar
up2
kullananlara ne
olmuş
boşa çıktıktan sonra
onu kullanmanızda
bir engel yok ki
bu
şimdi arkadaşımın sorusu
şuymuş
dikkatli izleyin
diğer arkadaşlarım da izlesin
belki aynı soruyu
onlar da soruyorlar
şimdi diyor ki
arkadaşım
benim diyor
elimde bir
unique ptr nesnesi var
ve dolu durumda
point
up
new point
ve şöyle bir kod yazdım
auto
bu up1 olsun
up1
u1
eşittir
up2
up1
soru
arkadaşlar
tabi move
sadece takip edin
soru
ben halen
up1'i kullanabilir miyim
cevap
tabi ki
up1
hayatta
ama
up1'i
direferans ederseniz
tanımsız
davranış olur
hoş durumda
ama up1
daha sonradan
yine dinamik ömürlü
bir nesnenin hayatını
kontrol edebilir mi
tabi ki
mesela
burada
up1
reset
arkadaşlar
efendim
near
point
yine
dolu duruma geçti
anlaşıldı değil mi
boşken dolu duruma
doluyken boş duruma
geçmesi
her zaman söz konusu
olabilir
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bir
unique ptr
nesnesini
hayata
getirmenin
ve hatta
onu dolu olarak
hayata getirmenin
bir yolu daha
var
aslında son derece
basit bir yol
daha önce ben
perfect forwarding
konusunda
zaten bunu örnek
olarak vermiştim
bakın bakın
şöyle yazmak yerine
unique ptr
evet
çağrı nereye
geleceğimi anladı
unique ptr'ın
point
açılımı
new
point
demek yerine
arkadaşlar
ya da genelleştirirsek
bakın bakın
unique ptr'ın
t bir tür olsun
t açılımı
constructora
new t
argümanları
varsa gönderiyorum
böyle
yazmak yerine
bir fabrika fonksiyonu
olan
make unique'i çağırırsam
make unique
birinci
template parametresine
karşılık gelen
template argümanı
yazmak zorundayım
didakşın imkanı
yok
örneğin
t
bu bir fonksiyon
şablonu
ve bu sefer
argümanları
constructora
göndermek yerine
arkadaşlar
bu fonksiyona
gönderirsem
birazdan
make unique'in kodunu
tekrar yazacağız
make unique
fonksiyon
şablonu
make unique fonksiyonu
bu argümanları
alıp
nev ifadesinde
t
türünden
bir nesneyi oluşturmak
için
t sınıfının
constructorına
bu argümanları
İngilizcese
perfect forward
edecek
ve bu fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
oluşturulan
dinamik
unique ptr
nesnesi olacak
dolayısıyla
böyle yazarsanız
arkadaşlar
aslında
derleyicinin
oluşturduğu
kod da
tabi
argümanları
yazmıyorum
isterseniz
point için
yapalım
mesela şöyle yazarsam
make unique
point
arkadaşlar
üç
beş
yedi
burada
ismi
make unique
olan fonksiyonu
çağırmış oluyorum
bu fonksiyona
argümanları
gönderdim
bu fonksiyonun içinde
birazdan kodunu
yazacağız
aslında bir
new ifadesi var
bu
new ifadesiyle
bir
point nesnesi oluşturulacak
işte
point nesnesini
oluşturmak için
çağırılan
constructora
benim
make unique fonksiyonuna
gönderdiğim
argümanlar
perfect forwarding
mekanizması ile
aktarılacak
dolayısıyla kodu
böyle
yazabildim ve çoğunlukla
şimdiye kadar
her ne kadar
arkadaşlar
hep
t yıldız parametreli
konstruktör ile
nesneyi
unique ptr nesnesine
oluştursam da
ondan çok daha fazla
biçimde
hem yazma kolaylığı
sağladığı için
hem de
new ifadesini
doğrudan
kullanmadığım için
make unique fonksiyonuna
çağrı yaparak
unique ptr nesnesine
oluşturmak
dahil
üstelik
make unique'in
arkadaşlar
geri dönüş değeri
türü olduğu için
Kaan Can
eski derleyicilerde
bu destek olmadığından
çok uzun bir
kullanıma sahibiz
aslında şöyle
tam öyle değildi
şimdi
C++11
standarda ilk çıktığında
bu bir
arkadaşlar
resmen
bugdı
yani
fabrika fonksiyonlarından
make shared vardı
ama
make unique
yoktu
C++14 de
onu tamir ettiler
evet
şimdi
fonksiyon çağrı ifadesi
r value expression
olduğu için
artık
bu ifadeyi
şu şekilde
isimlendirilmiş
bir nesneye
dönüştürebilirsiniz
ya da
bu ifadeyi
doğrudan
bir sağ taraf
değeri olduğu için
bir unique
ptr
nesnesine de
atayabilirsiniz
ya da
parametre değişkeni
unique ptr
olan bir fonksiyona
yapılan çağrıda
argüman olarak da
kullanabilirsiniz
yani şimdi
şunların hepsi
geçerli artık
void
full
arkadaşlar
stud
unique
ptr
point
soru
huyu doğrudan
bu ifadeyle
çağırabilir miyim
cevap
evet
neden
e çünkü
bu unique ptr
iteratüründen
ve bu ifade
bir
r value
yine
benzer
şekilde
eğer bir fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
unique ptr'ın
point açılımı
olsaydı
örneğin bu fonksiyonun
return ifadesi
make unique ile oluşturulmuş
şöyle bir ifade olsaydı
herhangi bir şekilde
senters hatası
olacak mıydı
arkadaşlar
cevap
hayır
çünkü
yine bu
bir sağ taraf değeri
peki
make unique
nasıl bir fonksiyon
arkadaşlar son derece
basit
ben daha önce
bir ya da iki kez
örfek forwarding
konusunu anlatırken de
bunu
yazmıştım zaten
bakın şöyle bir fonksiyon
template type name t
arkadaşlar
type name
ps
yani
variadic parametre paketi
geri dönüş değeri
unique ptr'ın
e açılımı
ismi
make unique
ps
orx
ne yapıyor
yavaş yavaş
yavaş
gidelim
new
p
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesne
oluşturacak
ama bu
nesnenin
konstruktörüne
arkadaşlar
neyi
argüman olarak
geçecek
gönderilen
argümanlar
ama bunları da
perfect
üretecek
yani stuat forward
args
arkadaşlar
gördünüz mü
burada
new ifadesi
yıldız
türünden
bir değer üretecek
yönetecek. Onu da arkadaşlar UniquePTR'ın
t açılımı türünden bir nesne oluşturmak için, geçici nesne oluşturmak için
UniquePTR'ın t yıldız parametre ile konstruktörünü argüman olarak göndereceğiz. Zaten burada mandatörü
bir alıcını oluyor. Dolayısıyla bunu doğrudan return ifadesi yapıyoruz. Bu da pratikte bakın
her ne kadar ortada bir fonksiyon çağrısı ve bir fonksiyon olsa da pratikte Unique'i böyle çağırmakla
Make Unique Point
Örneğin 3, 5, 7
ve fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerini
bu şekilde bir nesneye taşımakla
Aslında diğer ifadeyi yazmak, yani diğer bildirim yazmak, bakınız bunu böyle yazmakta
Yorum satırını alalım. Şöyle yazmak arasında
oluşturulan kod açısından hiçbir fark yok. Nasıl?
UniquePTR'ın
Point açılımı
UP
New Point
Diyelim ki 3, 5, 7
Ve ikisi de derleyicinin aynı kodu üretmesini sağlıyorsa
Siz hangisini kullanmayı tercih edersiniz?
Arkadaşlar tabii ki
Birçok kişi gibi
Siz de
Muhtemelen
Üsttekini kullanmayı tercih edersiniz
Daha basit, daha kısa
Derdini
Sentaks'ı
Daha kolay
Alian Bey'in dediği gibi
Derdini
Daha iyi anlatıyor
Şimdi
Devam ediyoruz
Daha epey yolumuz var
Arkadaşlar
UniquePTR nesnelerinin
UniquePTR sınıfının
Çok fazla üye fonksiyonu yok
Bu üye fonksiyonlarının her biri çok önemli
Şimdi iki tanesini gördük
Biri
Operatör
Yıldız
Diğeri
Operatör
Ok
Diğeri
Operatör
Arkadaşlar
Bull
Yani
Tür dönüştürüme
Operatör fonksiyonu
Ama bunun dışında
Lütfen dikkat
Sınıfın
Release isimli bir fonksiyonu var
Release serbest bırakmak demek değil mi?
Release fonksiyonunun
Geri dönüş değeri
Pointer türü
Yani
T yıldız
Ve
Release fonksiyonu çağrıldığında
Mülkiyeti bırakıyor
Ve
Raw Pointer döndürüyor
Yusuf'un dediği gibi
Ama bakın mülkiyeti bırakıyor
Nesneyi
Delete etmiyor
Boşa çıkartıyor
Ama
Geri dönüş değeriyle
Arkadaşlar
Kendisini çağıran koda
Hayatını kontrol etmekte olduğu
Nesnenin
Adresini döndürüyor
Şimdi bunu bir görelim
Burası çok önemli
Release'in kullanılması
Söz konusu olan
Yerler var
Arkadaşlar bakınız
Zaten taşıma semantiğinde
İmplementasyonuna
Baksanız
Release'in çağrıldığını
Göreceksiniz
Evet evet
Bakın
Make Unique
Artık
Make Unique'i
Kullanacağım
Bundan sonra
Görmeklerde
Make Unique
Point
Auto
UP
Yavaş yavaş
Gidelim
Sindire sindire
Şimdi
Örneğin
Sea Out
Yıldız
UP
Bu noktaya
Şöyle
Durdurmak için
Bir bakım açtı
Yetkan çağrısı
Koysam
Dinami gömürlü
Bir nesnenin
Oluşturulduğunu
Yani
New
İfadesiyle
Ve
Constructor'ın
Çağrıldığını
Göreceksiniz
Değil mi
Constructor
İçinde de
Yorum bakın
Evet
Point
Intintin
Adresi bu
Buraya kadar
Tamam
Şimdi devam
Arkadaşlar
İzleyin
Bu
Unique
Ptr
Nesnesini
Bir başka
Nesneye taşıyabilirim
Eğer
Hiçbir şey
Yapmasaydım
UP'nin
Hayatı
Bittiğinde
Zaten buradaki
Nesne
Ne olacaktı
Arkadaşlar
Destroy olacaktı
Ama şimdi bakın
UP'nin
Release'i
Ve
Release'in
Geri dönüş değerinin
Point
Yıldız olduğunu
Görüyorsunuz
Yani ister
Şöyle yazın
Auto
Ptr
Eşittir
İster
Alp
Dedaction'dan
Faydalanmayın
Şöyle yazın
Point
Yıldız
Ptr
Şimdi
Soru
Gekkar Çağrısı
Yapıldığında
Burada
Bekleyecek
Değerine
Sahip
Point
Nesnesi
Destro edildi mi
Edilmedi mi
Evet ya da hayır diye
Cevap
Hayır
Edilmedi
Ama
UP nesnesi
Dolu mu
Boş mu
C alt
UP eşittir
Arkadaşlar
UP
Dolu
Ve boş
Cevap boş
Boş
Oysa
Release'i çağırmadan önce
Doluydu
Değil mi
New Line
Bakın
Release'i
Çağırmadan önce
Ve çağırdıktan sonra
Dolu mu
Boş mu
Olduğuna yazdırıyorum
Arkadaşlar
Yalnız
Çok dikkatli olmanız
Gerekiyor
Neden
Artık
Boşa çıktığı için
Destroy
Etmek
Yani dinamik
Ömürlü nesnenin
Dinamik ömürlü nesnenin hayatını bitirmek
Geri dönüş değerini tutan pointer'a ait
Arkadaşlar
Buraya dikkat
Burada
Eğer
Fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerini bir değişkende saklamazsanız
Zaten anlamsız
Zaten
No Discard olarak bildirilmiş
B
Artık
Bu pointer'ı kullanarak
Nesneyi
Delete etmezseniz
Kaynak sızıntısı olacak
Bakınız
Alham dediğiniz gibi
Şu anda bir kaynak sızıntısı var mı?
Arkadaşlar
Var
Neden?
Çünkü
Boş durumda artık
Pointer
Null pointer
Dolayısıyla
Burada
Eğer böyle bir şey yapmışsam
Ki
Yapmamı gerektiren bazı senaryolar olacak
Arkadaşlar
Ne yapmam gerekir?
Delete
Kendim delete edeceğim artık
İçerliyorum
Bakın
Destructor'ın çağrıldığını görüyorsunuz
Burada
Kendim delete etmezsem
Kaynak sızıntısı olacak
Peki bir şimdi sizi zorlayacak bir sorun var
Arkadaşlar dikkatli izleyin
Unique PTR
Point açılımı
UPTR
Evet
Unique PTR'nin point açılımı
UPTR
Soru
Eşittir
UP
Yazmakla
Herkes dikkatli izlesin
Yani
Move UP yazmakla
Şunun arasında sizce bir fark var mı?
UPTR
Reset
UP'nin
Release'i
Bunlar sizce tamamen
Aynı
Sonucu mu doğru?
Yoksa
İkisi arasında bir fark var mı?
Cevap
Bravo Mehmet Can
Aynı
Arkadaşlar
Reset fonksiyonunda ben bir adres verdiğimde
O adresteki dinamik ömürlü nesnenin sahipliğini üstlenmiyor muydu?
Evet
O zaman
Release'in geri dönüş değeri dinamik ömürlü nesnenin adresi olduğuna göre
UPTR
O nesnenin sahipliğini üstlenecek
Ama UPT onu zaten sahipliğini bırakıyordu değil mi?
Release'e
Arkadaşlar bakın burayı anlamanız çok önemli
UPTR eşittir
Move UP yazmakla
UPTR'nin reset fonksiyonuna
UP'nin Release'ini argüman olarak göndermek
Aynı anlamda
Ya da şuna bakın
Arkadaşlar
Oto UPTR
Eşittir
Move UP yazmakla
Ne aynı anlamda?
Arkadaşlar
Oto
UPTR
Evet
Ya da Oto UPTR değil Unique PTR'nin yine türü yazıyorum
Point açılımı
UPTR
Yukarıdakini yorum satırına alacağım
UP'nin Release'i demek
Aynı anlamda
Yine Release mülkiyeti bırakacak
Böylece bu adreste yeni bir Unique PTR nesnesi oluşturmuş olacağım
Ama dinamik ömürlü nesne aynı nesne ortada herhangi bir şekilde bir destruction söz konusu değil
O zaman
Mekunic'e
Hayır
Mekunic'e argüman olarak gönderirseniz
Arkadaşlar Mekunic'e gönderdiğiniz argüman
Mekunic'e gönderdiğiniz argüman
Unique PTR'nin
Constructor'ın argüman olarak geçiriyor
Öyle değil mi?
Dolayısıyla
Unique PTR'nin
Constructor'ı
Sizden
Dinamik ömürlü bir nesnenin adresini istemiyor
Mekunic fonksiyonu içinde
Dinamik ömürlü bir nesneyi kendisi oluşturuyor
Burayı anladık mı?
Aynı şey değil Alihan
Mekunic'in demin kodunu yazmadık mı
Mekunic'in içinde bir niv ifadesi var
Evet
Mekunic'e gönderdiğiniz argüman
Arkadaşlar
Orada
Niv ifadesiyle oluşturulacak nesneye
Argüman olarak gönderiyor
Eğer şunu diyorsanız
Bakınız
Ben şimdi Alihan'a ve diğer arkadaşlarıma durumu açıklayayım
Mekunic
Point
Ve
Diyelim ki
Buna argüman olarak
Mekunic
Mekunic değil
UP Release
Sanırım sizin sorduğunuz soru böyle bir soru
Öyle mi?
Evet
Arkadaşlar bu durumda bu mülkiyeti bırakacak
Öyle değil mi?
Bu fonksiyonun geri dönüş değeri point yıldız olacak
Ama
Mekunic'in içinde
Oradaki niv point ifadesi var ya
niv point ifadesine
Siz bir point pointer'ı vermiş olacaksınız
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Yani dinamik ömürlü nesneyi
Dinamik ömürlü nesneyi
Dinamik ömürlü nesneyi oluştururken
Constructor'a gönderdiğiniz adres
Bir point nesnesi adresi olacak
Bu da tabi sizin istediğiniz bir şey değil
Evet
Peki
Şimdi geldik ikinci fonksiyona
Release'i öğrendik
Arkadaşlar ikinci fonksiyon
Get fonksiyonu
Çok önemli bir fonksiyon
Get fonksiyonu mülkiyeti bırakmıyor
Sadece
Geri dönüş değeriyle
Dinamik ömürlü nesnenin adresini iletiyor
Yani bakınız
Burada zaten çok kolay göreceksiniz
Soru
Ben şimdi
up'nin get fonksiyonunu çağırırsam
Birinci soru
Nesne destroy oldu mu?
Cevap hayır
Peki
Get fonksiyonundan aldığım adresi
Bir point pointer'ında tutsaydım
Point yıldız p
Bakın
Nesne destroy oldu mu?
Hayır
Önce bunu bir gösterelim
Yani buraya geldiğinde
Destructor çağırılmayacak
Gördük mü?
Arkadaşlar
up'ya boşa çıktı mı?
Hayır
Release olsaydı up'ya boşa çıkacaktı
Bu sadece adresi döndürüyor
Ve çok önemli bir fonksiyon
Siyah
up
dolu
ve boş
boş
halen dolu
takip edebildik mi?
Çünkü mülkiyeti bırakmıyor
Reset de etmiyor
O zaman Necat şöyle özetleyebilir miyiz?
Reset fonksiyonu
mülkiyeti bırakıyor
Yani nesneyi destroy ediyor
Release fonksiyonu mülkiyeti bırakıyor
Get fonksiyonu sadece adres döndürüyor
Gördüğünüz gibi
up'ya
dolu
Arkadaşlar
Yalnız çok dikkatli olmanız gerekiyor
Konunun sonunda
tipik olarak
C++ programcılarına
Bu akıllı pointer sınıflarıyla ilgili
mülakatlarda sorulan soruları örnek vereceğim
Ama beni ilgilendiren mülakat kısmı değil
üretim tarafı
Hep şöyle diyorum
Unique BTR sınıfı neden var?
Kaynakların daha güvenli bir şekilde kontrol edilmesini sağlamak
Kodlama hatalarını azaltmak
Ama benim şöyle bir cümlem var
Programcı
insanı
programcı kişisi
başını belaya sokmak isterse
her zaman başını belaya sokmanın bir yolunu kolayca bulabilir
İşte bunun için
hep şöyle sorular soruyorlar
Tanımsız davranış var mı?
Yanlış bir şey var mı?
Ya da buradaki yanlışlık ne?
Onu gösterin
Hadi ben size birkaç tane kod göstereceğim
Bu kodlarda yanlışlık var mı yok mu?
Bana söyleyeceksiniz
Evet
Mesela get fonksiyonunu bu şekilde çağırsam
Ve
Unique BTR
Point
Arkadaşlar
UPX
P
Bir problem var mı yok mu?
Cevap
Tabii ki
Büyük bir problem var
Arkadaşlar
Unique BTR nesnesi
Kaynağın tek sahibi olacaktı değil mi?
Çok güzel bir cevap vermiş
Yani
Unique'lik gitti demiş
Tabii ki Unique'lik gitti
Siz
Arkadaşlar
Aynı dinamik ömürlü nesnenin adresiyle
İkinci bir Unique BTR daha oluşturdunuz
Yani bu durumda
Yani bu durumda her iki Unique BTR'nin içindeki pointer aynı nesneyi gösteriyor
Farklı nesneleri değil
Dolayısıyla
Arkadaşlar
Senin hayatı bittiğinde
Diğeri
Dandling pointer olacak
Bakın mesela çok tipik yapılan hatalar ve çok tipik sorulan sorulardan biri bu
Get'in geri dönüş değeriyle
Arkadaşlar
Yeni bir Unique BTR nesnesi oluşturmak
Peki soru
Burada çağrılan get fonksiyonu olmasaydı
Release fonksiyonu olsaydı
Burada bir tanımsız davranış ya da kötü bir durum olur muydu?
Cevap
Hayır
Ama zaten bunu taşıma semantiyle yapabilirdim
Sadece
Farklı şekilde yapmış olduk
Peki
Devam
Arkadaşlar
Unique BTR
UP
Get
Delete
Burada bir sorun var mı?
Cevap
Bravo olsam
Tabii ki tanımsız davranış
Neden?
Çünkü ben bunu delete ettim
Ama UP'nin destraktörü çağrıldığında
Standing pointer'ı delete edecek
Yani double deletion dediğimiz
Durum oluşacak
Anlaşıldı mı?
Peki bir soru daha
Bakınız
Oto
P
Eşittir
Near Point
Arkadaşlar
Unique BTR
Point
UP1
P
UP2P
Burada bir problem var mı?
Cevap
Tabii ki var
Yine 2 Unique BTR nesnesi de aynı kaynağı gösteriyor
İlk soru gibi
Bravo
İlk sorudan
Herhangi bir şekilde
Bir farkı
Yok
Peki
Soru
Arkadaşlar
Unique BTR
Ya da şöyle diyelim
McUnique
Point
Oto UP
Oto
PTR
Eşittir
U
P'nin
Arkadaşlar
Bit'i
U
P
Reset
Siyah
Yıldız
PTR
Hata var mı yok mu?
Bütün bu senaryoları
Bravo
Artık gördünüz değil mi?
Neden hata var?
E çünkü PTR
Danging Pointer oldu
Değil mi?
PTR Danging Pointer oldu diyorum
Arkadaşlar
Bakın PTR Danging Pointer oldu
Null Pointer değil
Yine bir yanlış anlama var
Null Pointer'ı direferans etmiyoruz
Danging Pointer'ı direferans ediyoruz
Hoş
Null Pointer'ı direferans etseydik
Yine tanımsız davranış olurdu
Alihan
Ama niye Null Pointer'ı direferans edelim?
PTR'nin değeri Null Pointer değil ki
PTR'ye değeri
Burada verdik
Burada Null Pointer değil ki
Get fonksiyonundan geri dönüş değeri
Alihan anladınız mı?
Ama reset ile
Nesneyi delete etmiş olduk
Şimdi PTR Danging Pointer oldu
Yani problem PTR'nin Danging Pointer olması
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet
Arkadaşlar
Get fonksiyonu önemli bir fonksiyon
Önemini birazdan göreceğiz
Ama ilginç bir soru daha
Bakınız
If
U P
Yazmakla
Sizce
If
U P
Eşit değil
Null Pointer
Sadece bekleyin
Eşit değil
Null Pointer
Dört tane if deyimi yazdım
Hangisinin anlamı farklı?
Oğuzhan bir daha düşünün
Kaan Çan bir daha düşünün
Cevap şu olabilir mi?
Hiçbirinin anlamı farklı değil
Ama Necati soruyu öyle sormadın
İşte koşullandırmak için
Şimdi if U P ne demek?
U P boş değilse
U P'nin boş olmaması demek
Pointer'ının Null Pointer olmaması demek
Get fonksiyonunda zaten pointer'ı get etmiyor mu?
Lojik ifade bağlamında bir pointer değişkeni kullanabildiğime göre
Böyle yazmak zaten
Get'in geri dönüş değeri Null Pointer değilse demek
Get'in geri dönüş değeri Null Pointer değilse
Zaten U P dolu
Dolayısıyla doğru cevap ne?
Muhammed Yusuf
Dördü de aynı anlama geliyor
Anlaşıldı mı?
Peki birkaç tane soru daha
Ziyahut
U P'nin get'i
On dördüncü satırdaki Statement'la
Standart Output'a neyi yazdırmış olurum?
Cevap
Neyin adresini ama Cengiz Han, Oğuzhan
Neyin adresini?
Dinamik ömürlü nesnenin adresini
U P'nin adresini değil
Bakın bakın U P'nin adresini değil
U P'nin adresi başka
U P'nin adresi adres U P
Öyle değil mi Oğuzhan?
Bu U P'nin adresi değil
Bu dinamik ömürlü nesnenin adresi
Peki şimdi bir sürpriz
U P'yi bu şekilde kullandığımda
Bir sentaks hatası olmadığına göre
Çağrı Oğuzhan Yiğit
O zaman bu da legal
Buradan tahmin edebiliyor musunuz?
Sınıfın bir insörter fonksiyonu var
Insörter fonksiyonu
Yine
Neni insörte diyor streame
Dinamik ömürlü nesnenin adresini
Yani U P'nin kendi adresini değil
Aradaki farka bakın
Arkadaşlar
İlk iki adres aynı olacak
Ama üçüncü adres
U P nesnesinin kendi adresi
Aradaki farkı anladık mı?
Demek ki
Sınıfın bir de insörter'ı var
Insörter olan fonksiyon
Bir streame
Unique PTR nesnesini verdiğimizde
O streame
Aslında neyi yazıyor o streame?
U P'nin hayatını kontrol ettiği nesnenin adresi
Tabii ki boş olsaydı
Null pointer'ı yansırmış olacaktık
Anlaşıldı mı?
Evet
Peki soru
U P
Nokta get
Hangisi
Hangisi sentaks hatası?
14 mu 15 mi?
Yoksa her iki streame mi?
Arkadaşlar
Burada
Dinamik ömürlü nesnenin adresini aldığıma göre
O adresteki nesne için set fonksiyonunu çağırdım
Fakat buradaki ok operatörü
Zaten
Unique PTR sınıfının ok operatör fonksiyonu
Dolayısıyla ikisi de aynı
Yine
Sizi
Koçullandırma yönlendirmeye çalışıyorum
Doğru cevabı
Vermekte zorlanın diye
Ama
Bravo
İkisi de
Aynı anlama geliyor
Değil mi?
Herkes anladı mı?
Tamam
Arkadaşlar şimdi
Gelelim şu
Deleter
Mevzuna
Şimdiye kadar bizim kullandığımız örneklerde
Deleter türü olarak
Default delete'i kullandık
Yani aslında
Şöyle yazmakla
Unique PTR'ın
Point açılımı
Arkadaşlar
Demekle
Unique PTR'ın Point açılımı
Stude
Default delete'in
Arkadaşlar
İzleyin
Point açılımı
Yazmak arasında
Bir fark yok
Şimdi birşeyi görmenizi istiyorum
Şöyle bir sınıfım olsaydı
Struct
Deleter
Bakın
Struct
Point Deleter
Bu sınıfa ben şöyle bir fonksiyon yazsaydım
Void
Operatör
Fonksiyon çağrı
Point Yıldız
Arkadaşlar
Const
Ve burada da şöyle bir ifade olsaydı
Delete P
Bakım edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet
Ve burada da
Unique PTR'ın
Point virgül point deleter açılımı deseydim
Ve bu nesneye
Argüman olarak
New point
Böyle bir argüman ifade verseydim
Yine aynı şekilde
Buradan yaratılan dinamik ömürlüğün esne delete edilmiş olur muydu?
Scope'un sonunda
Cevap evet
İşte zaten default delete bunu yapıyor
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Bakın runtime'a
Peki şimdi soru
Bu fonksiyonu böyle yazmak yerine
Bu fonksiyonun kodu farklı bir kod da olabilirdi değil mi?
Mesela bir örnek verelim
Diyelim ki her delete edilen point nesnesi için
Bir loglama yapıyor olsaydı
Böyle bir isteği olsaydı
O zaman sadece delete etmiyor
Default delete bunu yapmaz
Ama bakın
To see out
Arkadaşlar
The point object
At the address
Arkadaşlar
P
Is
Being
Deleted
Diyelim ki
Böyle bir statement olsaydı
O zaman
Unique.ptr nesnesinin
Destructor'a çağrıldığı zaman
Unique.ptr'nin destructor'ı başta da konuştuğumuz gibi
Bu fonksiyonu çağrılmasını sağlayacak
Main
Is
Running
Yani bu yazı çıkmadan
Benim yukarıdaki yazıyı
Arkadaşlar
Görüyorsunuz
Çıktığını göreceğim
Yani delete etmekten başka
İşlem ya da işlemler yaptırmak istiyorsanız
Custom bir Deleter kullanmalısınız
Ama şimdi
Custom Deleter kullanmanın
Ooo
Bir sürü yolu var
Bir
Şöyle bir
Ne yazabilirsiniz
Panther class yazabilirsiniz
Örnekte olduğu gibi
Arkadaşlar
İki
Bir lambda ifadesi kullanıp
Arkadaşlar
Lambda ifadesinden oluşturulan
Clojure type'i kullanabilirsiniz
Bakın bakın
Kodda küçük bir değişiklik yapalım
Auto
Eftel
Eşittir
Point Yıldız D
Arkadaşlar
Ve
Şu kodu buraya alıyorum
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet
Ve şimdi
Burada
Point Deleter türü
Yerine
Yukarıdakine kalsın
Decl type
Eftel
Arkadaşlar
Yalnız dikkat
Daha önce de konuşmuştuk
C++
İtibariyle
Hatırlıyorsunuz değil mi?
Bu
Burada önemli değil ama
Stateless
Namdaların
Default
Constructor'ının
C++
20'den önce
Deleted
Olduğunu hatırlayalım
Ama burada zaten
Bir fark yaratmayacak
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet
Arkadaşlar
Böylece
O zaman
İkinci template parametresine
Karşılık gelen
Template
Argümanı
Decl type
Eftel
İfadesiyle
Elde edilen
Tür olacak
Yani Eftel'in
Türü olacak
Hatta C++
Elimiyle henüz anlatmadım ama
Lambda ifadelerini
İngilizce karşılığıyla
Unevaluated
Kontekste kullanabiliyorsunuz
Yani
Eğer
Görüntü kirliliği
Olmayacaksa
İsterseniz
Şunu silelim
Bakın bakın
Size ilginç bir şey göstereceğim ama
C++ 20
Bu benim lambda ifadem değil mi?
Bunu aldım
Decl type
Lambda ifadesini
Buraya yazdım
Bu da C++ 20
İle geçerli
C++ 20
Standardında
Arkadaşlar
Unevaluated
Context
Denilen yerlerde
Yani
İşlem kodu üretilmeyen
Bağlamda
Lambda ifadesini
Kullanabiliyorsunuz
Decl type'ın operanda olan ifade
Unevaluated
Kontekste olduğu için
Doğrudan
Lambda ifadesini
İsimlendirilmiş
Bir değişkene
Dönüştürmeden
Burada
Bu şekilde
Kullanabiliyorsunuz
O zaman
Kullanacağınız
Dileeter'ı
Elde etmek için
Ayrı bir
Arkadaşlar
Panther
Class
Oluşturabilirsiniz
Hatta bu sınıfı
Nested Class
Yapabilirsiniz
Ya da doğrudan
Lambda ifadesiyle
Oluşturabilirsiniz
Gerçek bir fonksiyon da olabilir
Şimdi kodu biraz daha değiştirelim
Bu kez
Fonksiyonun ismi
Arkadaşlar
Örneğin
Delete Point
Fonksiyonu olsun
Artık
Delete Point fonksiyonu
Gördüğünüz gibi
Bir
Free Function
Yani
Global
Bir fonksiyon
Şimdi
Bakınız
Unique
Ptr'nin
Point
Decl type
Şurası vardı ya
Bunun yerine
Arkadaşlar
Decl type
Adres
Pan
Delete Point
Ya da
Doğrudan
Fonksiyon adresi türü
Ya da
Doğrudan
Fonksiyon adresi türü
Yani
Void
Yıldız
Point Yıldız
Ama bu durumda
Fonksiyona
İkinci bir argüman olarak
Fonksiyonun adresini
Geçmek zorundasınız
Geçmek
Anlaşıldı mı
Dolayısıyla
Bir fonksiyonu
Bir Free Function'ı
Bir
Closure Type'ı
Ya da bir
Founter Class'ı
VLiter olarak
Kullanabilirim
Ama şimdi
İki dakikamız daha var
Bir dahaki derste
Devam edeceğiz ama
Asıl
Önemli olan
Örneğe başlayalım
Kaldığımız yeri
Belirleyelim
Arkadaşlar
En baştan beri
Ben size şöyle
Bir cümle
Söyledim
Dedim ki
Dinamik ömürlü
Nesne olmak
Zorunda
Değil
Bir
Kaynağı da
Sonlandırabilir
Asıl gücü de
Bence burada
Sadece dinamik ömürlü
Nesnelerle değil
Bakın şimdi
Çok dikkatli izleyin
Class
List
Using
List handle
Eşittir
List
Yıldız
List handle
Arkadaşlar
Create list
Void
Bunlar
Diyelim ki
C
Hapisi
Burada C olmasını bozan
Sadece bu
İsterseniz
Bunu da şöyle yazalım
Halptef
List yıldız
List handle
Takip edin
Bu da bitiş fonksiyonu
Void
Destroy list
List
Ve
List handle
Örneğin sonuna kadar
Bekleyin
Diyelim ki
Bir fonksiyonun içindeyim
Void foo
Burada normalde
Şunu yapmam gerekiyor
Bir liste oluşturmam gerekiyor
Diyelim ki
Bu bağlı liste sınıfı
Olsun
List handle
Eşittir
Handle
Söyleyin
Create list
Burada kodlar var
Bla bla bla
Ve burada
Programcı
Destroy list'i çağırmış
Destroy list
Handle
Şimdi soruyu çok dikkatli izleyin
Burada
A
Destroy list
Fonksiyonunun
Çağrılması
Unutulsaydı
B
Burada çağrılan var fonksiyonu
Exception
Throw etseydi
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
O zaman
Kaynak sızıntısı olurdu
Değil mi?
Peki
Burada
Unique ptr ile
Durumu kurtarma
Şansın var mı?
Cevap
Tabii ki
Bakın
Bakın nasıl?
Arkadaşlar
Kendi
Dileader'ımı kullanarak
Değil mi?
Bitsin
Böyle bitirelim
Bugünkü dersi
O zaman
Şöyle yazabilir miyim?
Stud
Bakın
Oto
Eftel
F'den
Eşittir
Arkadaşlar
List handle
A
Ve
Söyleyin
Neydi ismi?
Destroy list
A
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Tamam
O zaman şimdi ben
Deleter olarak bunu kullansam
Deleter türü olarak
Eftel'in türünü kullansam
O zaman
Bu fonksiyon
Çağrılacak
Değil mi?
Bu fonksiyon da
Destroy list
Ama nasıl kullanacağım
Burada?
Asıl kritik yer burası
O zaman şöyle kullanacağım
Değil mi?
Unique ptr'nin
Arkadaşlar
Ne açılımı
Ne açılımı?
Soru
List açılımı
Upt
Ama ikinci template parametresi olarak
Decl type
Eftel
Diyelim ki
Uptr
Arkadaşlar
Create List
Umarım kaçırmadınız sonunu
O zaman
Unique ptr nesnesi
Arkadaşlar
Destroy olduğunda
Yani
Unique ptr nesnesini
Yanlış yere yazmışım
Zaten mi?
Uptr yazmışım
Uptr nesnesi
Destroy olduğunda
Çağrılan
Operatör
Fonksiyonu
Yani bizim buradaki
Lambda fonksiyonumuz
Create list
Destroy list
Çağıracak
Değil mi?
Böylece kaynak
Geri verilmiş olacak
Ama şimdi ben size
İki ya da üç kez
Bugün
Get fonksiyonu
Çok önemli
Dedim
Neden get fonksiyonunu
Çağıralım ki?
Sorusunun cevabına
Bakın
Peki bu API'yı
Nasıl kullanacağım?
Burada
Mesela
Arkadaşlar
Pushback isimli
Fonksiyon
Temsili
Efendim
List handle istiyor
Başka argüman da olacak
Yani
Burada
Handle sistemindeki
Fonksiyonlar
Handle istiyor
Dolayısıyla
Biz
Uptr ile
Uptr'yi
Kullanarak
Bu fonksiyonu
Nasıl çağıracağız ki
Pushback'i
İşte
Aslında
Get fonksiyonunun
Geri döndürdüğü adres
Bizim istediğimiz
Handle
O zaman
Örneğin
Pushback fonksiyonuna
Nasıl çağrı
Yapacağız?
Pushback
Uptr
Get
Şimdi
Get'in önemi
Daha iyi
Anlaşılıyor
Değil mi?
Arkadaşlar
Özür dilerim
Uptr
Nokta
Get
Bu haftaki derslerimiz
Sonra yarıyor
Ve
Bir dahaki hafta
Arkadaşlar
Görüşmek üzere
İyi akşamlar
Diliyorum
Oradan bunu bir sonraki
Dersin başında
Tekrar eder misiniz
Demiş arkadaşım
Tabii ki ederim
Zaten bir iki örnek
Daha vereceğim
Custom Deleterlarla ilgili
Daha bir 15 dakika
Daha
Konuşacağım
Görüşmek üzere
Değerli arkadaşlarım